[Music]
thank you
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday night it's Christmas Eve Eve yeah
hopefully everybody can hear us yeah
spooky music on spooky holiday music
well yeah you know you know how I do
it's a holiday I gotta do like special
[ __ ] just for Halloween and Christmas I
don't usually bother with the other
holidays it's Friday yeah getting you
guys ready for the weekend
the Christmas weekend yeah it's
Christmas weekend yeah I have a feeling
Jenny wanted to go out tonight
well I do but it's like I can't afford
it yeah
money's kind of tight
yeah money money is very tight uh this
month actually it was tight last month
but it's even tighter this month
so uh so yeah is there anything going on
yeah this is the worst this is the worst
somebody sent us money thank you
grandmothers I like little snowflakes
and everything yeah the um
um I was gonna say I don't know
what what was actually going on tonight
did they say
I thought it was Memento Mori
but I could be dead I could be wrong
it's right before Christmas man that
would be dead
yeah we missed the last one too which
was like two weeks ago they started
doing it twice a month but like last two
weeks ago I really didn't have any money
thank you again Graham there's he said
it's like a dollar
hey it all adds up yeah you know they
take 30 of that
I mean wait they would take 30 they'd
take 30 if he says two dollars too so it
wouldn't be the same that's what I mean
it's like it doesn't really matter the
um
um I was gonna say about okay then they
um
[ __ ]
it's gonna it's getting cold tonight
people I had to go out there and [ __ ]
cover up all the [ __ ] uh
uh plans I mean it's not as cold as it
is I mean
uh it's minus 20 in Michigan it's not
getting that cold it's gonna it's gonna
be uh what do you call it it's good for
a tropical area it's gonna be cold here
yeah it happens every now and then yeah
um but it's usually just like one night
and then it's warm again right now it's
6 p.m where we are and it's 57 degrees
at least according to my thing yeah so
so it's going down to like 30 so all our
plants are gonna die
I think it's gonna be all right cover
them up with plastic some of them I uh
wrapped Christmas lights around try to
get some heat underneath there make like
a little Greenhouse
this is a little smudge box yeah around
the banana trees that I got growing in
there put uh what do you call them
pillowcases
put pillowcases and then trash bags over
those yeah and then tied it
we'll see okay
grafter says I'm gonna have all the damn
green peppers I picked
because they were they were about ready
anyway well they they I don't I don't
really know like green peppers can't
survive the cold is that what it is I I
was doubting it so I just I just picked
them yeah grandpa says grandfather says
I'm gonna make it rain tonight like a
guy sit in front wrote a strip bar hey
that's all right
Ben said I saw Christmas Bloody
Christmas and it was terrible was that
the one that I was asking about that was
on shutter because I haven't watched
that one yet I really wanted to do more
Christmas horror movies thank you again
granthers weird messages cost at least
two dollars do they really I didn't know
that I've never like I don't usually
watch other like live streams so you
know so I don't know like how that whole
situation works but I've been wanting to
watch like more
Christmas horror but I just haven't
really had time it's like I even I was
planning on doing a video for scare
Salon it is done it's just that I
haven't it only just now finished like
processing I only just now like 20
minutes ago finished editing it and I
haven't made the um the thumbnail image
for it or anything like that so I'll
probably wait till tomorrow to put that
one up even though I was gonna put it up
today so I can put a different one up
tomorrow and I still have to finish
reading that [ __ ] uh Christmas horror
story book that I was reading and like
get a review of that put up like
sometimes Before Christmas time but
we'll see how that works out I mean you
know if I can't do it I'll have to wait
till next year
because I actually had a message from an
author who sent me a couple of his books
and I said that I would review them like
by the end of the month and I haven't
got to it yet and they weren't like
Christmas themed
but I'll probably guess them
uh Ben said yeah the one with the killer
Santa robot and a loudmouth protagonist
yeah I mean I might still watch it
anyway but
now I might like wait if you said that
but
yeah the the video that I just finished
editing was not so much about a movie it
was about like all those um what do you
call them The Rankin bass like stop
motion Christmas specials like from back
in the day because I rewatched three of
those like not all of them because there
was a couple that I didn't really like
give a [ __ ] about but
I watched the three main ones and uh did
a video about that which is about like
40 something minutes long I think but
I'll probably wait till tomorrow to put
that up because I didn't finish it quite
but yeah so
it's kind of uh
it's 29 here says murder Hornet yeah
it might I don't know I didn't I didn't
see like I saw on my my other little
computer over there yeah it's in Texas
yeah my other little computer over there
like it warns you when it's gonna freeze
it has like a little it says
temperatures plummet and then has a
little like
like a thermometer on it that like it's
all blue and has snowflakes on it so I
kept seeing that but then sometimes too
that thing will tell me that it's like
sleeting and snowing outside and I'm
like is it no it's like 60 something
degrees I'm like [ __ ] it's not
snowing so I don't really know what its
deal is
Camp guy said one degree Fahrenheit here
this morning the high for the day was
about five or six degrees in North
Georgia Mountains I mean I had heard
that it was going to be like super cold
because there's all kind of like really
bad storms because everybody's travel
plans are being disrupted because
they're being snowed in and blizzards
and whatnot so there is that I did hear
about that but I didn't realize that it
was going to be that cold down here
you all right you're not very talkative
I'm thinking about cooking
we only just started why are you
thinking about cooking because I have to
I got the I got the turkey uh out it's
thawed it should be good by the time
well when are you you're gonna make it
Sunday right yeah that should be good
I'm just well see the thing is I could
also thought in the refrigerator but I'm
trying to figure out you know how long
should I leave it out before I put it
back in the refrigerator you know
because it'll kind of slow thaw in the
refrigerator but I don't not making it
not having to make the stuffing [ __ ]
saves me a lot of time a lot of effort
well yeah I kind of feel like that was
the most that was the most time
consuming yeah I mean the turkey once
you kind of get it all prepped and stick
in the oven you just gotta like wait for
it to be done yeah keeper you got to
keep basting it then you gotta make
turkey gravy well now with the few times
that I made turkey for Thanksgiving like
before I met you I was always
um told that it's better not to keep
opening the oven to baste it because it
[ __ ] up your cooking time like because
you keep letting heat out and I actually
didn't open it to baste it I what I did
was I just um coated all the outside
with olive oil and then like I just put
it in there and I didn't open it to
baste it I just left in there and it
came out perfectly succulent well I got
the
it's in a big roasting pan and then I've
got
um aluminum foil over the top of it too
so it's like a it's almost like in a
dutch oven type situation it's hot you
know what I mean the the turkey's hot so
putting it back in it doesn't lose that
much uh well I did that too I did that
too
it's okay though they've been good [ __ ]
how many yeah I cooked for you yeah no
I'm just I'm just saying that it's like
if you didn't want to do that extra step
I'm not really sure how much difference
it makes is what I'm is what I was
getting at because I've done I've done
it without basing it before and it
turned out it turned out perfectly fine
good well I only based it like two or
three times oh twice it's not like I'm
doing it all the time that's true I'm
just checking it
um when you check it then I'll baste it
just again
and then um what else is that thinking
okay it's gonna be all right oh um
save this save some money on the ham
spiral cut ham
was twice the price of just a regular
boat in ham
Christmas ham so I got I got just I
didn't get spiral cut I cut it I mean
really what's the difference it just
makes it easier it's easier to serve
it's all about it easier to serve you
can core that bone out of it and pull it
out and you've got to cut it and you
gotta carve the turkey anyway so might
as well yeah it's not it was like half
the price
yeah big spiral cut was like 20
something bucks or uh yeah and then like
just the same ham not spiral cut was 10.
so I was like oh [ __ ] yeah I'll cut it
for ten dollars
yeah what's the point it even came with
the damn
um sugar sauce what do you call it [ __ ]
you know what do you call that [ __ ] you
cover it with the glaze it's the glaze
yeah it came with the glaze pack too
yeah
[Laughter]
I mean technically that's what it is in
Mississippi when I was a kid I'd get
confused as [ __ ] my my grandmother old
Southerners called
spaghetti sauce tomato gravy sometimes
really yeah just I don't even think I've
ever heard that in any any kind of
Italian
tomato sauce you know like because they
didn't know what that [ __ ] was yeah they
would just call it but yeah they would
call it they would call it tomato gravy
they're not calling them my dad didn't
yeah my dad didn't but my grandmother
did okay put my tomato gravy on there
what tomato sauce you know yeah
tomato grape marinara sauce ooh fancy
yeah
well actually when I looking back on it
it would it wasn't really marinara it
was more like Bolognese because they had
ground up hamburger in it too yeah so it
did have some gravy in it some hamburger
gravy we pretty much always had
spaghetti sauce like that yeah what with
your hamburger in it yeah yeah it's
actually called Bolognese
yeah yeah I know that I'm just saying
that that was usually how we made it
which is fine with me although honestly
I like I like um tomato sauce with just
like big chunky veggies yeah like big
chunks of peppers and stuff yeah I like
it like that then my dad would make red
eye gravy
which had something to do with coffee
grounds but then he also made tomato
gravy but it was nothing to do with
with uh tomato sauce it was just a
tomato gravy that you put on grits
yeah remember that
I don't think we ever made that yeah it
was just it's just a red gravy
because it was okay
yeah yeah I didn't think it was anything
special
well see that's what included that and I
think well we that's what I was gonna
say because when we were working on the
cookbook we could have the fuse we were
having a discussion about red eye gravy
because you were saying that red-eye
gravy was like that tomato and I'm like
no it's not it's I got confused it's ham
drippings and coffee coffee like black
coffee is what it is uh coffee that's
right I thought it was maybe coffee
grounds no it's but no it's like black
coffee okay and ham drippings I think as
far as I thought he had coffee grounds
inside of a [ __ ] cloth bag or
something was pressing it in the bottom
of the pan yeah I guess I could do it
like that too because he got it out of
the coffee maker yeah you know the drip
coffee yeah like the old yeah or
something he took he took the coffee
grounds out put them in a towel I think
and put some hot water in the top of it
and then just Twisted it and squeeze it
so he was just making coffee making
coffee out of the coffee grounds through
his through his dirty ass towel
extra flavor it was just a regular towel
a lot of the you know regular towel that
you get for you know because
a lot of Southern Homes don't use early
but back in the old days didn't use
paper towels they used kitchen towels
I mean that's what's what I use just
wash them over and over again he used
one a little kitchen towel but you know
it was it was in the morning I remember
we were getting ready we were getting
ready it was like [ __ ] four o'clock
in the morning
because we were going we were going
hunting so you're going to eat before
the the hunt
and the coffee was being made me
drinking the coffee and he was making
grits and [ __ ]
bacon and [ __ ]
and out of that bacon he grabbed the
the grounds on the top the coffee maker
because it had already made the pot of
coffee and then threw that in a towel
and then
put hot water in it squeezed it and
squeezed it into a pan it was dabbing it
into the bottom of the pad like I said
then they'd put yeah I think he did the
bacon yeah you put bacon drip inside
yeah bacon dripping and I think some
flour or something and made a gravy out
of that and then threw the grounds away
yeah that thing make it and um because
nothing was wasted
it was good it was real good I don't
love it it's okay but it gives it some
kind it gives it kind of a smoky flavor
yeah but then he would make tomato gravy
and it was kind of like it was pale pale
red
think of it like pale
it's just like a pale Red Gravy it was
good
thank you again granthers we were
talking about turkey he said be sure to
save the neck for your dad
[Laughter]
although I think you use the knife I use
for gravy using gravy I mean a different
neck
and the gizzard
I don't use the liver really I've used
it before but I like it but a lot of the
people don't like it
it's a little strong yeah I could take
it or leave it you know and I and then
like out of the stock pot
that had the uh the celery and
everything
I'll take that in the stock pot water
and use an immersion blender and [ __ ]
blend it and turn it into just like a
green water and thicken it
and then I'd have two gravies going like
a
vegetable gravy
and then a turkey gravy yeah and they're
all using both yeah they're all the
vegetable gravy I put a little bit of
gizzard
so it's not vegetables
what's got the vegetables in it right
but I'm just saying it's not vegetable
right no and it's got turkey neck meat
in it
turkey neck meat yeah and you never
finish it all yields so much you can't
eat it all
but it's easy to make a big amount it's
cheap yeah thank you very much thank you
next Dimension media thanks for a year
of great shows like a lot of folks here
it's been a challenging year but we'll
get through it happy holidays Jenny and
Thomas everyone here in the chat thank
you so much that is like so awesome I'm
gonna talk you all right to the edge of
the damn apocalypse and then when the
power goes out you're on yo
yeah
uh okay
we'll see Dave is here hello and merry
Seasons to all thank you very much happy
holidays I don't know what we're gonna
like I said we're probably just gonna be
laying around eating all weekend yeah
can't afford to go to a place
[Laughter]
most people are with their families
anyway there's not going to be anybody
out
that's true every time we've done that
before okay we've done it before
nobody's out
yeah I feel like other holidays like
people do like to go out but Christmas
not so much you don't usually New Years
they're out well yeah everybody goes out
on [ __ ] new years maybe we'll do you
New Years although yeah
mannequins is doing
on New Year's Eve which is a Saturday
night so you know it's gonna be [ __ ]
insane
um they're doing or at least this is the
poster they asked me to do
a blackout fetish party okay meaning
they're going to turn all the lights out
and uh big Tom said he was going to give
prizes to the people that wore the least
amount of clothes okay we're going
and it's supposed to be like really
really dark in there yeah maybe that's
why he's giving prizes except he's like
freezing their tits off yeah
I don't know how that's gonna go so
you're gonna get like groped by a bunch
of strangers and you're not gonna be
able to see who they are
which you know depending on your
proclivities I'm not really sure how
happy you'd be about that
I was like that sounds like a disaster
way to happen
and honestly like if he leaves it like
really dark in there I was like I was
thinking while I was making the poster
I'm like how like what happens when
everybody gets like really really drunk
and they're all like falling over and
like tripping over each other and stuff
it's not gonna be totally dark in there
it can't be because they well you still
have to have like the accent lights on
all the little lights for all the little
lights for the little uh uh [ __ ]
refrigerators and everything all the
little you know with with the shots yeah
and then all the special effects lights
and everything you can't it's not gonna
be
it's gonna be totally dark in there this
is that's just gimmick Zach said he's
only turning the lights off so everyone
doesn't see how bad everyone else looks
naked
yeah that's kind of what I was thinking
too yeah about it's about half and half
he says
where will they keep their money well
you know when your crowd's looking good
women have uh we we have Nature's purse
we have some place to put it yeah you
want to hand it to other people but yeah
Nature's purse
Ned's got that too the prison's purse
we'll see what women have too we have
two of them so it's like we have two
places that's some gross [ __ ] man
the uh well hey you know yeah somebody
probably yeah so maybe we'll maybe we'll
do New Year's yeah we'll see we'll see
where everybody's going they're probably
going to mannequins
I mean like I said that's the Saturday
night so I'm not really sure and I'm
sure it's gonna be [ __ ] packed
because remember we went there
we went there on Halloween and it was
[ __ ] packed you could barely even
move in there yeah he's gonna be making
big money yeah
Grandfather said I'm taking my kids to
see avatar on Christmas
I told them today it will be a visually
spectacular movie but with a dumb plot
about tall blue Smurfs yeah and they
were still they were still like oh that
sounds like a cool idea yeah I haven't
seen anything about it but you know I
heard it's mediocre I well you know I
kind of thought the first one was media
yeah I thought the first one was
mediocre like it was pretty to look at
but I don't really remember that much
about it it was just it's funny because
it was and like the funny thing about it
was that it's it's one of those movies
that was like a massive deal at the time
like everybody saw that [ __ ] but then
like five years later like nobody talked
about it which is really really weird
because there's two different kind of
movies there's movies that are kind of
like very of the moment and everybody
sees them and it's like ooh but then
there's movies that maybe a lot of
people liked him at the time but then
like you know 10 years later everybody
still remembers it 20 years later
everybody still remembers it and talks
about it and stuff like that but Avatar
was like not one of those movies I
thought battle Angel was much better and
they never did make a sequel to it
they're not interested in making a
sequel to battle angel
remember
yeah it wasn't that long ago I know I
like that and that was that was David
Cameron too all CG James Cameron or
James Cameron yeah all CG stuff
yeah much better yeah it was all right
that's all right um that's not better
than Avatar
well it's better than that that's what
I'm saying that was much better than
Avatar
but you know it's I'm not like I said
I'm not usually into those really big
like spectacle movies like that so much
it's not usually my favorite thing
you know I just thought it was shitty
sci-fi
what Avatar yeah
Zach says a man like Tom is there and
thinks he's grabbing his drink except
it's not his drink yet that's uh I kind
of feel like um I kind of want to go
just to see what happens like
just to see like I don't know because I
had all kind of like scenarios that
might occur like in that situation I get
paid right before there so
yeah we'll we'll be able to go oh okay
yeah you always get paid on the first I
I get paid like sporadically at like
different times so it's not like it's
not like I have a big bulk at the
beginning of like the month I'm always
just got paid and got a VA raise
well that's good yeah I saw it I was
like okay it sounds good
uh they're trying to they're [ __ ] up
the economy so they said well we have to
pay these guys a little bit more because
uh all their money's going away to
[ __ ] groceries because groceries are
so expensive now
Zach says it took him 35 years to make a
sequel to Blade Runner but they still
did it so don't lose hope yet yeah
that's what I mean and it was still good
yeah that movie was amazing so you know
it can be done
it can be done just because something's
old and it's just like well I mean look
at I don't know why I just thought of
this but like look at um you know the
series Cobra Kai yeah which is like kind
of based on that you know the movie from
the 80s but and that's [ __ ] great
so it doesn't really matter how much
time has gone by
but what have we been
watching and doing and what were you
watching last night Unsolved Mysteries
right yeah that's right yeah we've been
watching like the new season of Unsolved
Mysteries they really seem to I guess
maybe this is what people ask for but
they really seem to be like leaning into
because they had a UFO episode and then
they had an episode that was about
um
like the what do they call them like out
on the Navajo reservation and that one
was a little bit about UFOs but then
also Bigfoot and also Skin Walkers like
they were just talking about like
Paranormal like all kind of paranormal
[ __ ] that they saw which
I don't know it's I just kept like
wandering in and out of the room like
doing other stuff like well that one was
I don't see that one because it wasn't
really that interesting I mean they but
I kind of feel like I like the ones more
where they focus they do kind of like a
deep dive on one case like that's like
more interesting this was just kind of
like more generalized like oh and by the
way I went to this house and it was
haunted and yeah and then some people
said they saw like a Bigfoot and I saw a
skin walker running by my car and [ __ ]
like that and I was just kind of like
okay so it didn't really have any Focus
you know what I mean
but yeah so so I watched that one and I
was like meh and then there was that one
about that kid
that was his name Josh
he had like a Josh Fox that was his name
no he had like a French last name and he
was from
Michigan Minnesota
and he disappeared like he went to a
poker party one night and then he just
like got up and apparently everyone else
at the party like thought he was just
going to the bathroom or some [ __ ] and
then he just like went apparently like
back to his apartment which was just
like less than a quarter mile away like
across campus it was on like a it was
like a um religious College like where
he went
and somewhere between this guy's house
and his apartment like he just vanished
and they have no [ __ ] idea where he
went to yeah John it's the same music
and no um no host which I think it's
good because you're not gonna be able to
replace oh what's his name Robert Stack
yeah so there's no host at all
um they just they just got the format to
where it just goes through the case and
they play that kind of spooky music but
it sounds real good but I thought that
was a group a great uh you don't need a
host and they probably knew that too
they just said you know that was very
much of the time of place and it's like
you can't really beat
you know him being on the show and it's
like if they anybody else was just gonna
pale in comparison and it would just be
filler to have somebody yeah a hostage
it just fills up time that was a TV
thing and it was a TV thing of it of the
era right you don't you don't need that
nowadays so let let Robert Stack's
material rest is [ __ ] iconic just
um but you got it it's a good show the
way the edit's really good
um the cases that they show are pretty
interesting the way the way they show
them
it is a little bit generic other other
shows kind of do that same format but
but they're doing it because it works
yeah and then they have the the Unsolved
Mysteries branding with the [ __ ]
theme song and [ __ ] going through it so
it's good real good I like it and that
UFO episode Jane didn't like UFO
episodes but the UFO case that they
talked about was a real good one yeah
it's called something in the sky I mean
it was interesting it was interesting
like for UFO stuff but it was just I was
so so tired I was like I fell asleep
sitting up like while I was watching I
was like it was about something that
happened in the 90s up near Michigan a
radar operator
saw a damn blip on the screen and
tracked it for several hours out over
Lake Michigan and a bunch of people were
calling the police there was a big wave
of sightings that night them seeing
these lights in the sky just single
lights and they would join together and
they'd break apart
some people actually saw the craft but
they just a woman said it was a smooth
cylinder but they showed a disc
so maybe she didn't know what a cylinder
was or or whatever I don't know if there
took Liberties or what
um but it was it wasn't solid per se it
was merging together with other lights
and then they'd break apart and they'd
go around patterns and we're not talking
everybody saw it said it was trying to
be seen you know it wasn't elusive it
was up there for hours evidently cops
for seeing it cops were calling and says
yeah I don't know what it is it's a
bunch of Lights
they were up around 6 000 feet some of
them were lower
and it went out over the water
and one and
the radar operator he he uh
he confirmed that it was over this over
Lake Michigan or I think was Lake
Michigan
in a place where it wasn't frozen over
about six thousand feet above the
surface according to the radar breaking
apart making patterns and then going
back together
and uh it was there for several hours
and
it was stationary for a long time and
during that time one of the Witnesses on
the ground said it was pulling water up
out of the ground and like a [ __ ]
waterfall that was reversed going all
the way up about six thousand feet into
that craft and it was sucking water for
like a long time
and it wasn't a very big craft so that's
pretty damn mysterious it's pulling
water up in a tractor beam
you tell me I don't know
what does it need fresh water for
or you know
maybe they saw it maybe they polluted
all their water one Whatever Planet they
were from
and that thing evidently wasn't that big
I mean how much water did it take is it
bigger on the inside than it is on the
outside whatever it is it's not
a machine I don't think
it's or a lot of it's in another
dimension
Tom Sykes says Tom and Jenny which of
the two film Which films would you
rather watch Dante's Peak or volcano
both from 1997. never seen it that's
right there's like I think I've seen one
of them but I can't remember which one
it was they're probably like either one
they're probably both fine I kind of
feel like that was yeah there was all
those those two volcano movies came out
the same year I kind of feel like there
was a little mini boomlet of like
disaster movies like in the 90s granther
says some other movies that were once a
big deal but then everyone forgot about
them crash yeah not the David Cronenberg
one the other one with the ensemble cast
I think I saw that in the theater and I
remember kind of liking it but yeah I
kind of forgot about it after
um the island yeah Dirty Dancing I don't
know about that because I think Dirty
Dancing is still pretty iconic
um and honestly if you've seen that show
on Netflix the movies that made us they
did a whole episode about Dirty Dancing
about how that's still like a big thing
so I think that's the only one I'd
probably argue with
um and anything with Adam Sandler yeah
any of his I guess people still talk
about do they still talk about some of
his stuff like uh what's I don't know I
haven't seen any of them man the water
boy and [ __ ] like that I like Waterboy
Waterboy was okay as far as a uh I don't
I don't really like that kind of like
really juvenile humor like that that was
his best but like a lot of comedians
like that like him and Jim Carrey and
stuff like that when they give them a
dramatic role they can actually usually
really act yeah which is crazy that one
movie that he was in he played that
Jewish gangster that was uncut gems
uncut gems that was a great [ __ ]
movie [ __ ] Masterpiece that was one
of them that movie made me like more
anxious than maybe any other movie that
I've ever seen except maybe hereditary
and that was based on a real story
dude the wrote the story was his son
well like I said he had done some other
kind of more dramatic roles to like in
Spanglish and stuff like that and so he
can act same thing with Jim Carrey I
can't stand like his Jim Carrey shtick
like hey I'm talking out of my butthole
I'm like okay great
um that's like not funny is cocaine
driven it's yeah it's just like it's too
much I'm just like [ __ ] dial it back
a little bit but when he when they give
him a dramatic role like he was [ __ ]
great in uh Eternal Sunshine at the
Spotless Mind he was [ __ ] fantastic
in that so you know and you know
obviously um what's the what's the
[ __ ] The Truman Show he was great in
that too uh Zach said it's always so
weird saying Robert Stack in old movies
and you realize he was kind of a looker
back in the day he was actually he was
like a really good looking dude John
Smith said when I was a kid I really
love the ghost segments on Unsolved
Mysteries
yeah I like the ghost segments too I
mean the True Crime ones are my favorite
but the ghost ones are good too uh the
True Crime ones were always creepy too I
remember one about someone that found a
creepy Polaroid of kidnap victims that
was probably the Tara Calico case
because I think that was like a big
thing about it I had the three kids side
by side well it wasn't three it was a it
was an older girl and like a little boy
yeah and they found like a um Polaroid
in a convenience store parking lot I
want to say yeah I still don't think
they've solved that you know that but
then I think we talked about it I don't
know who that is though right they knew
who those people were well I don't know
if they know who the boy is okay but
they know who the girl was
unless I'm remembering it wrong but I
kind of I thought that had to do with
like the Terra Calico case and actually
they don't know if that's her or not I
think that was the thing is that they
found that and there was a girl named
Tara Calico that's been missing and they
don't know where she is and the girl in
the picture kind of looks like her but
they're not entirely sure if it's her or
not maybe that's what I'm like okay
because I've read about so many cases
that it's like I get them mixed up
sometimes but I do remember that detail
and I remember that picture because it's
pretty famous
um Camp guy said I used to not believe
in any UFO stuff but now the Tic Tac
stuff with the Navy and some of their
other pictures and video is pretty
interesting yeah but here's the thing
the the videos that they're showing that
they've released are not very good all
right they look good on the surface but
then when you see a deeper analysis of
them
they're
they're misidentification like okay
here's
here's one of the main ones
the guys are trying to get a lock on
what looks like a small object moving at
a very high rate of speed over top of
the water and he's able to get a [ __ ]
lock on he goes whoa I got it I got it
and they're going yeah look at that
thing boy it's moving yeah
the thing is is that it's not actually
moving fast at all and it's not in
anywhere near the water it's an effect
called parallax
um
you if you if you're into if
if you have a rifle scope
and you're in say like a helicopter
with the doors open and you point that
rifle out of the
door of that helicopter
at something halfway
between you and the ground let's say
it's just a paper bag blowing in the
wind
and you put that rifle scope on it and
you're trying to track it as the chopper
is passing it
behind it in the scope you're going to
see the ground moving by real fast
and it's going to look like that object
is [ __ ] close to the ground moving
real fast but it's not you're passing it
and because
you're tracking it through that scope
the
the image of the ground behind that
object you're looking at start it looks
like it's it's moving by fast because
the it's an effect called Parallax you
can you can look up a better description
that I can then I can explain
you're looking through a tube and you're
trying to track something
as you're passing it and behind it you
see the ground moving like that it gives
the illusion that the object's moving
real fast it isn't
so what they locked on to if you asked
me
was a paper bag it was something just
blowing in the wind wouldn't that be
funny if all this [ __ ] have all this
brew HaHa was about that it seemed some
like out plastic Walmart plastic Walmart
bag or something like that they saw it
or or a balloon or something and there
it and
they saw it [ __ ] what is that and they
tried to lock on the damn
uh it's like a camera out of a pintle
it's to help
identify incoming targets and [ __ ]
control your
missiles and [ __ ] you know I don't know
the name of that stuff they update it
all the time
so they were able to get a lock on that
thing optically
and it just gave that Parallax effect I
think it was I think it was mostly
standing still I think it was just a
plastic bag
and it wasn't anywhere near the surface
of the of the water it was probably up
thousands of feet in the air
and then um so they show that one then
they show another one where it looks
like an object and it's kind of like
looks like a light looks like a bright
light in the shape of I don't know kind
of like a kind of like a a disc or
something
and as they turn it turns in the
opposite direction
that looks like some kind of a glare of
an object and a camera on the end of a
pencil having a problem it looks like a
mechanical problem with the tracking on
that camera
because that camera's in a pod out on a
wing
trying to look through a little glass
nose cone
and at certain angles it kind of can't
it has a problem tracking things you
know what I mean because it's it can
spin this way and it can move this way
and it's in that little nose cone
so I didn't buy it was some kind of a
reflection or some kind of mechanical
problem but
according to people who've seen these
things and were involved in these cases
the videos that they're showing the
public art is not the good stuff that
the good stuff they haven't released
they're showing you the shitty stuff the
good stuff's classified
because when they were doing the Tic Tac
stuff they did get photos of it
but according to those Pilots the good
[ __ ] is not was never released they kept
it
because the one that they're showing it
every time they start talking about the
the Tic Tac UFO
where he turns and that thing turns and
there's it's just a it's just kind of a
crappy video that's not from the guys
who saw the Tic Tac in the first time
that was for the second group of guys
that came
and thought that they saw something near
a waypoint I thought they saw that but I
don't I'm not convinced that's the same
object
but
the intelligence agencies are convinced
that some they said yeah there are uaps
unidentified Arrow phenomenon they they
don't think they're man-made
uh they got
classified
data and they've got classified video
but it's not released
it's all I can say you you tell me what
it is I don't know
they know there's something up but I
don't think they know anything about it
this is
the thing is is that you know a lot of
people believe this Roswell stuff know
that they have downed craft and I don't
[ __ ] buy that not one bit
I think that they don't know what it is
that's what I think
Richard Brown said have you ever seen
the British TV series strange but true I
think I have but it's been a while
um Zach says I love Dante's Peak but man
is Brosnan an up and down actor and some
things he's really great and others he's
really terrible same with Sharon Stone
yeah I've noticed I haven't noticed that
uh about Pierce Brosnan because I
haven't seen him enough things but I
have noticed that about Sharon Stone
though Karen gamble said hi guys happy
Christmas Eve Eve I just watched Legend
with Tom Hardy yeah that's a great
[ __ ] movie The Christmas Eve back to
you happy Christmas Eve
uh Zach says I still say Sharon Stone's
best movies are the first Basic Instinct
and Casino
man casino is such a good movie I need
to like re-watch that one again I
remember really liking that
also Tom Sykes says Dante's Peak that
movie mentions the Mammoth Mountain
volcano
so there you go
I don't remember if I've seen that one
maybe I saw a volcano
I don't know
Zach says it's also weird when we were
talking about uh comedic actors being
good at trauma it's also weird how
conversely a lot of dramatic actors
usually aren't that great at comedy yeah
it doesn't usually work the other way
does it sometimes it does but
I wonder why that is that's very
interesting yeah Camp glasses that thing
could have been a sun dog which is a
[ __ ] reflection inside that's what I
kind of think that was like a sun dog
and uh had something to do with the way
that that camera moved inside that
pencil in there and the sun dog kind of
rotates and it's opposite the way the
camera moved because when he turns that
jet and then that image turns exactly at
the same amount of degrees the same rate
that means it's some kind of reflection
that they're showing
thank you camp guy thanks Cameron Merry
Christmas thank you very much thank you
very much thank you very much thank you
Elvis saying thank you very much yeah
yeah we know
um Tom sack says the 2018 film the man
who killed Hitler and then the Bigfoot
starring Sam Elliott is a pretty good
flick I've been wanting to watch that
because how could you not want to watch
something with a great title like that I
mean you know
um yeah Sharon Stone was okay in Total
Recall yeah I remember her being okay in
that
but you know I just depended on how much
cocaine you gave her
yeah maybe that's maybe maybe that's
what the what the measurement is a lot
of that a lot of it is edit okay
um yeah I think like and I think I've
said this before but editors are kind of
like the unsung heroes or villains of
Hollywood because they can really make
or break a movie yeah I mean uh Bill
Paxton in Aliens comes off as a [ __ ]
great character in uh most edits but you
see deleted stuff or extended edits of
aliens that has more of [ __ ] Bill
Paxton's playing uh playing that
colonial marine he's annoying
he's like man he's terrible at it
but in the in the in in your average
um theatrical cut he's great
because a lot of his bad [ __ ] was cut
out
yeah because they were like well there's
a certain percentage of that character
that most people are going to be able to
take yeah so we have to like know well
that's what I'm saying much of his ass
in there right that's what that's what I
mean it's like the thing about an editor
is they always have to know that's a
real talent in itself I don't know if
I'd be very good at that
you know what I mean I mean all this
[ __ ] game over man I mean that was
[ __ ] great and it's just some of the
[ __ ] that he does in the in the
theatrical cut [ __ ] great
but you see the long cuts of him be like
man get that [ __ ] out of here
well any character that's real over the
top like that is gonna great on people
after a while so you have to really know
when to Reign that in yeah like when
he's in the drop craft talking to Ripley
we got the plasma cannons we got this
and that we're here to be he gives me
this big long spiel to Ripley about how
they're going to protect her from the
aliens and he does a good performance I
guess you say it's a good performance
but there's too much of it yeah there's
too much of him in well it's too big of
a character you really and if you have
too much of that in a movie it really
steals the spotlight from the other
characters yeah yeah and it ends up
being more kind of in a just an annoying
distracting right kind of a character
um so editing him down made him look
[ __ ] much better as an actor
yeah
well that's why in a in a lot of ways I
don't necessarily I mean there are
exceptions as well of course but I don't
necessarily like to like [ __ ] on actors
for ruining a movie because it's not
usually I mean sometimes it is pretty
clearly but a lot of times because the
thing about it is that most movies are
not shot in sequence
um you know and so
they they kind of just do it in little
bits and starts and then it's edited
together later so it's like a lot of
times they don't really know how the
final because it's it's pretty common
for like actors to be like man I thought
this is going to be a great movie and
then I saw the Final Cut and I was like
what the [ __ ] it's like you know what I
mean like I remember shooting all those
scenes but when you put them in that
order and like all this other kind of
[ __ ] it looks like a big flaming like
pile of ducks you know what I mean so it
does actually like really make a
difference like how it's put together
yeah but had you seen
stuff of Sharon Stone that got cut out a
total recall it was probably [ __ ] a
flaming pile of [ __ ]
less is more you know I mean they
probably edited her down into a tight
character that [ __ ] made sense and it
was all her best takes and there it is
you remembered it you say oh she was
great in that movie editor probably had
a lot to do with it
yeah like I said editors I think they
don't they don't get enough uh credit no
Star Wars well I think somebody
mentioned that saved and edit yeah that
would have been a piece of [ __ ] well
that's probably the most famous one that
was like
and it was going to have a disco
soundtrack
I had heard that yeah it's gonna be
disco and then they said please tell me
somebody did a fan edit like that on
YouTube there has to be and everybody's
done everything on on the internet
somewhere it'll be disco and uh then
later on they were like no we're gonna
have to give this thing a [ __ ]
classical at it you know and then it
it all came together I can imagine like
Chewbacca like walking down like through
the [ __ ] Millennium Falcon while like
some Bee Gees were playing or something
that'd be kind of awesome well it was
1977 it made sick it's 1977 and it was
sci-fi it made sense that it would be
Disco
because it had to be cool and kind of
futuristic
going classical that's going backwards
but it does yeah because that's like old
people so I guess the old people
[Laughter]
but they knew it but
I'm gonna give it to the British man
those British Studios knew what the [ __ ]
they were doing and the dudes that
saved that movie and the dudes that
built all the [ __ ]
sets and the costumes
you're like well this is Star Wars well
wait a minute we got the Empire we got a
rebellion we got this this is this is
the war we grew up with we're talking
about the 30s and the 40s so they you
know because these are World War II
veterans that are doing this so we're
gonna take it back to like oh World War
II propaganda movie so they went that
way and that that then it worked yeah it
totally did and then that's because that
was the absolutely right decision now
set the tone for that entire franchise
and when you get away from that you're
[ __ ] up Star Wars you're just making
Star Wars fan fiction okay when you
start getting away from 1930s 1930s
1940s that's what you're talking about
even the [ __ ] Mandalorian that's kind
of 30s and 40s
the tone and Old West it's the old west
Samurai movies
well I've argued that if you're the
thing is if you're trying to make a
movie I think this is why a lot of
people
um why there are certain movies that
don't age very well if you're trying to
make something of the moment I think we
discussed this a little bit when we were
talking about that hammer movie Dracula
80 1972 yeah where they were trying to
make everything just like very hip and
modern to that time period problem is
like yeah it might be cool for like a
few months like when you do that but
then like 10 years from now everybody's
gonna like watch that and be like what
the [ __ ] is this nonsense you know what
I mean it's much better to to make
something that's like you take some like
[ __ ] from old stuff because then it
won't like age you know what I mean it's
classic and traditional stuff generally
yeah yeah it's already nostalgic in a
way yeah because then it won't it won't
seem like you know it's just kind of
like when you see all those movies in
the 80s where they made everybody have
like break dancing and all that kind of
stuff and it's like now they just seem
ridiculous well you can look at [ __ ]
movies that are done right or all the
ones that [ __ ] I grew up with that
[ __ ] they all stuck you can they all
[ __ ] held up
and you can show them to young people
today that they've never seen him and go
man that's the best we've ever seen and
that's going to be Raiders of Lost are
okay that first Raiders lost ark they're
all good but the first one is timeless
okay and it's because it's it's said in
another time set in the 30s you know
yeah because it was it was old when it
was made right it was homage cereal
and it still holds up see because it's
got a lot of Timeless stuff in it
Predator all right everybody loves
predator what's funny is that if you
watch reaction videos which I study that
on YouTube the people that are reacting
people have never seen it
disproportionately women love [ __ ]
predator
and they and the girls like I didn't
think I was gonna like this movie this
is a great movie you know [ __ ]
because
these are these are younger women
and it's because that's a good good
story and there's and people would say
it's a very Macho very masculine script
all right and you know it's [ __ ]
written by [ __ ] soldiers and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] performed by soldiers most of
them guys starring that movie had
military backgrounds
but it appealed to women too there was a
there was a women characters in there
okay that remember the rebel Soldier
yeah and uh
[ __ ] in a way it kind of had elements
of female fantasy in there you know the
[ __ ] scary big hot dudes you get
captured by them but then it turns out
you're scared of them but then it turns
out they're your friends they're
protecting you you know what I mean and
then you come back and save the maid
Alpha dude in the helicopter yeah so it
there is a female so it's not as
it's not as [ __ ] male driven as you
think a lot of that stuff is not as cut
and dry it's not as good because I kind
of feel like until probably the 90s
maybe later I kind of feel like there
was a an erroneous perception that women
didn't like horror for example and I
think that's [ __ ] I think it was
always kind of like almost half and half
or maybe like a little bit less than
half for women but there's always been
women that were in a horror yeah and
it's like
so so I don't really get where they
always like thought that they just
marketed it toward dudes because it's
like there's a lot of women out there
that like that [ __ ] too yeah you know
what I mean it's not as cut and dried as
that well it's just story good story you
know yeah if you have a good story and
characters that you care about then it
doesn't like it doesn't matter if you're
a man woman or whatever it's like
everybody likes that [ __ ] yeah you know
what I mean
and then there's the thing about it too
is that some things that are marketed to
women like womany movies that I can't
[ __ ] stand I don't like I do not like
rom-coms I don't like I mean like I said
I like that one though I've seen ones
that I've liked because I knew that you
were gonna say that yeah I've seen ones
that I've liked I'm not saying that I
hate them across the board I'll watch
anything if it's good you know what I
mean I don't really have a have a thing
about like I'm not gonna watch that
genre but we saw this realm com with
that little fat girl in there and
[ __ ] I've laughed through the whole
[ __ ] thing I like that movie Saw the
theater what was it called it was it was
making fun of rom-coms yeah like gently
it wasn't like mean-spirited but yeah it
was like it was parodying yeah but it
was a great movie yeah it was feeling
good I was like that was a refreshing
movie it was really funny yeah
uh the craft almost all female leads and
I thought I thought the craft was great
when it came oh that's a horror movie
that's not a rom-com yeah no no I'm just
talking about female Orange movies oh I
was talking about Ron Collins no [ __ ]
craft I believe was for a female
audience but [ __ ] I like that movie it's
good yeah
um what else is for a female audience
that I thought was good
um I don't know maybe Ginger Snaps I'm
talking about like other horror movies
gender snaps was good Ginger Snaps is a
great [ __ ]
um
and I'm surprised when Ginger Snaps came
out I think I mentioned this on our
review of it that we did a long time ago
I was like I'm amazed that I don't think
up until Ginger Snaps came out nobody
that made a werewolf movie had ever
thought to link werewolves and
menstruation before
and I was just like duh it seems like so
obvious in retrospect but like that was
like the first big movie to do it
another one that holds up
uh has been um that young people
watching they go man that was a badass
flick and that was the thing they like
that one and that's all dudes okay I
don't think I've ever met a single
person that didn't like the thing and uh
the the female reaction is really good
they're like man that was a great movie
you know [ __ ] it's just a weird
[ __ ] movie it was even better when it
was new and you saw it on the big screen
and you'd never see anything like that
before that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
man
I kind of wonder sometimes
I don't know if this is true it's
probably not as true as it maybe it used
to be when I was growing up but I do
kind of feel like maybe
I feel like it's harder for a dude to
watch a movie that's all female
characters and relate to it than it is
for a woman to watch a movie with all
male characters because normally like
you know because we see movies with male
mostly male characters like all the time
so it's not really that big of a deal
we've just gotten kind of gotten used to
it and we can like relate if it's a man
it's a woman it doesn't really matter
but I kind of feel like sometimes like
dudes have a harder time like it's like
I don't want to see a movie that like
that's all women characters like that
it's almost kind of like a turn off you
know what I mean I say no I don't know
if that's true I'm just wondering I just
wondering it's gonna depend on what the
topic is that's true and what the story
is like we saw that Suspiria all right I
thought that with all those witches yeah
I thought it was interesting you know I
think there was a problem with the
script that was it was a little long and
it was real kind of convoluted
but I thought the characters were
interesting yeah you know they're
talking about the new Suspiria yeah not
the original no not the original the new
Suspiria it needed to be cleaned up I
really wanted to like that movie because
it did have a lot of interesting
characters in it
um but it was it had kind of a
convoluted script a little too it wasn't
streamlined enough for me
and then by the time the grand finale
happened I was kind of taken out of it
when that damn witch came out killed all
the other ones that demon came out I
thought that was pretty cool but I'm
trying that was the only one that's all
female that I was thinking of I don't
think there was any men in that one
um yeah well there was but when you say
the male character I think was played by
a woman although they didn't you didn't
know that until the end we talking about
all female I can't even really think of
all there's not well you know what's
crazy is there's not many like you can
think of a lot of movies that had all
new characters no I mean you can have
think of a lot of movies that had uh
almost all or majority like dude
characters and like the women were just
either not there or were just like tiny
characters but when it's really weird
it's just kind of like you know like
back in the old days like when you had a
band like you have a band right and it's
all dudes if you had a band that was
like had one woman in it or was all
women that was the first thing everybody
would mention about it whereas like if
the band was all dudes nobody would men
would nobody would even because that was
kind of occur to them to mention it well
that's what I'm saying because they had
to so I kind of feel like it's the same
thing with movies like if you have a
movie that like the thing or you know I
don't know I'm trying to think of
something else like The Expendables or
something like that that it's like 99
dudes characters yeah
um nobody really comments that much
about it but if you have a movie that's
all female characters then everybody
like has something to say about it which
is interesting
you know I just I just find that really
interesting
you tell them Advance right no I said
movies movies well they're just not that
many of them that was made I guess there
isn't that there aren't as many
situations where it's just all women
there's a lot of situations where for a
movie where it's all guys
you know what I mean your military
movies World War II it's gonna be all
guys pretty much
who's on a damn spaceship or underneath
the underneath the bottom of the ocean
it's gonna be guys you know it's just
that's a good setting for a story
Gladiators even though they had female
gladiators but they did mostly going to
be [ __ ] guys all right
it's just the way it is
um
if it's all female then where is this
taking place at a girls school they have
those
a lot of porn movies just all [ __ ]
women but that's what I was gonna say
implicit in that is the idea that
anywhere that a movie that realistically
had all female characters was set would
but it would not be interesting yeah you
know what I mean
although didn't everybody really get
into that TV show Orange is the New
Black and that was set in a women's
prison
so you have to write it the right way
and you have to you know what I mean
well that's true of anything because to
be honest I've seen lots of movies with
male characters female characters in a
mixture and like you know some of them
are just not good and it doesn't have
anything to do whether it's all dudes or
it's all women or not it's like the
stories aren't good you can't say I'm
gonna make
I'm gonna I'm gonna this is gonna be an
all-female movie and that's gonna make
us good no
no well being a good movie there's got
to be a good movie
you know I mean that's part of the
problem with that Hollywood does well
we're going to have a bunch of diversity
and it'll be good no it's got to be a
good movie and then you know what I mean
and then the diversity adds to like Ugh
the Predator was diverse that was a
diverse cast
but you didn't think of it at the time
it was just natural because it was a
good movie that's the way an elite
military unit in real life looks it's
white guys Hispanic guys and black guys
that's what it looks like that's not so
it didn't feel it didn't feel artificial
everything about it felt natural it felt
it normal you know
if you're [ __ ] start
from some kind of weird artificial
mindset of like this is going to be a
movie and it's going to be all female
because that will make it good no it
won't work it has to be a good movie
first well you have to have a
justification
whatever it is that you're doing well I
mean whatever it is like whether the
characters like whatever
um they are like what even whatever job
they have or whatever everything just
has to make sense because otherwise I
mean at least in context of like the
universe that you're creating because
otherwise people are going to be taken
out of it and it's going to make people
like think of you have to make
everything just seem like it I could
make a badass off all female movie
well let's talk about an awesome let's
talk about a badass all-female movie The
Descent yeah that was so good I could I
could even chop that one
I could make a movie where it's Mad Max
okay
all the men have died there aren't any
men a virus killed them all there's only
women
all right Matt what what if what would
happen then
and then there's a couple dudes that
survived sure we'd be quiet around here
that's for sure
[Laughter]
then there'd be like a couple dudes that
survived all right and the women are
fighting over these [ __ ] dudes
I'm already I'm already not believing
that
yeah I can picture it the women would
not be fighting
I think well I think I think the [ __ ]
well they wouldn't with women want
children
a lot of them would want children then
human race would be dying see
so they become real high priority to
have these men
like I saw a movie like that and then
you can have most women would be like in
these lesbian relationships but they but
they were kind of like forced into it
you know what I mean because there
wasn't any other choice
so then like the [ __ ] few dudes that
were surviving
would be like Superstars but they'd have
to keep him in a maximum security kind
of facility
to like keep them safe
all right because they'd be [ __ ] rare
imagine that
I didn't know like I've seen something
like that and it and then it would be
like [ __ ] this society would be
insane okay I don't think it would work
out too well it would just be one gender
yeah and I think that would it would be
like prison all right be like a women's
prison
and they'd be doing [ __ ] like killing
each other
be a bunch of crime
I don't think it'd be peaceful I think
it'd be crazy
it would just change the difference down
here
I don't think it would be crazy I don't
think it would be the same
now okay uh I I kind of feel like if all
the women on earth died off
I think all the men on Earth would
probably kill each other within a year I
think it would just be completely insane
it might
they start fighting over boys probably a
lot of them well I mean they would
probably start fighting over everything
I'm just saying that the other way
around like if all the men died off and
then there was only women left I'm not
sure it would play I'm not I'm not
saying it would be good I'm just saying
I don't think it would play out the same
way I don't think it would play out the
same way
you know you'd be dealing with you'd be
dealing with a [ __ ] collapsing
civilization because it's population
well yeah but that's a whole other issue
there wouldn't be every year there'd be
fewer and fewer people and you wouldn't
be able to maintain
basic Services eventually uh it would it
would end up being like Mad Max it would
be the end of the world it'd be the
Apocalypse you couldn't keep
you couldn't keep the human species
alive
so people would start doing [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] they'd be doing great
because there would be a future
this is wood you know the future would
only be as long as the youngest person
the youngest male that was around you
know
so a human lifetime
do you remember that episode of Masters
of Horror that was called the screwfly
solution my favorite one that was your
favorite one my favorite one yeah it was
basically about a VI well it was like a
virus that caused aliens to put a virus
that put a virus on the earth and like
it made the men like go crazy and like
start killing the women like it made
them like super misogynistic
what made him confuse sexual attraction
with [ __ ] homicide so like they're
basically all became like serial killed
they all are like just [ __ ] that was
wrong with their brains that's wrong
with serial killer brains were they like
equate sex and violence yeah dudes are
getting [ __ ] found guilty or arrested
and then the cops are letting them go
because they feel the same way about it
they're like yeah don't worry about it
yeah kill them [ __ ] yeah kill them
yeah there's a screw is a [ __ ] spooky
[ __ ] episode
yeah
yeah I remember that yeah but yeah it's
just I don't know I don't know it's it's
an interesting thing to kind of think
about
um I'm really behind on the comments so
I apologize uh Donald Taylor says Paxton
killed it Bill Paxton killed it with
Frailty yeah that's a great photo I talk
about it he directed that too yeah it's
a good movie Merry Christmas guys
I've said it many times that's one of
the best Christian movies that one in
Noah but yeah I mean because normally
and I've said this before like normally
when you have the Trope and you don't
see this that often but when you have
the Trope in horror where it's like oh
the religious people read all along
um you know usually that kind of like
pisses me off but in that case it
absolutely did not because I think they
just [ __ ] they nailed that it was it
was amazing yeah Tom Sykes said Bill
Paxton was in the decent horror Thriller
slasher film butcher Baker nightmare
maker which is an underrated gem I have
actually been one I haven't seen it but
I've been wanting to see it like I think
shutter added it not too long ago and I
don't know if it's still on there or not
but I remember when they added I was
like oh [ __ ] I gotta watch that and then
I put it on my list and then I never got
to watch
uh John Smith said there is a Star Wars
disco album out
okay now I gotta have that somebody did
please tell me somebody put that on
YouTube because I want to hear it
let's see
um Master and Commander uh never talk
about Hell Comes to Frogtown
yeah I wanted to do that that had Rowdy
Roddy Piper in it
you know you didn't see that did you
which one Hell Comes to Frogtown
um
is it good it's all right if you like
rat if you like Rowdy Roddy Piper I
liked him in uh they live yeah he did a
great job and they live for a dude who's
not an actor
that was a great movie yeah and I liked
the script
yeah Keith David [ __ ] knocked it out
of the park too one of the longest fight
scenes in [ __ ] history
try to get him to [ __ ] put the damn
glasses on
to see who the enemy was
wait I missed something in here that
sounded like funny
the Expendable Golden Girls wait what
somebody talking about Coyote Ugly I
remember that that's an all-female movie
I remember that one being good too but I
haven't seen it in a long time I don't
remember liking that but I haven't seen
it in a very long time so okay I don't
remember it it was kind of like just a a
movie of its time you know I think even
[ __ ] Tom Cruise made a bartender
movie around that same time yeah it was
called cocktail yeah yeah
and he was one bartender and he was
being like smug and I wanted to smack
him just like most of the movies that
he's in yeah
that's what I said just like every other
movie he's doing I want I want to like
punch him right in the mouth makes you
want to see that movie uh that
where he was he he was the Assassin
again what was the name of that one
collateral collateral yeah I want to see
that one again you should probably see
Magnolia I keep telling you that every
time because any anytime people
anytime he plays an [ __ ] he's good
yeah because that's probably like I
don't know but it's probably like closer
to his actual man I like Oblivion
okay yeah I like I like that too yeah
Tom Cruise in a Bluetooth he Jenny
bagging oh bagging on Tom Cruise hey I'm
gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
allowed to have an opinion I'm gonna
[ __ ] defend Tom
my namesake I'm gonna [ __ ] depend I'm
gonna defend him
no he I uh he's good he's good
he's good his movies are consistently
high quality
I think sometimes he's miscast
you know I mean like they'll put him in
something where I yeah I really wouldn't
like he shouldn't have been in Jack
Reacher okay
he did a good job in it though
but that character is [ __ ] huge in
real life that's what she's a big dude
Tom Cruise is my size
yeah it didn't really I mean I kind of
thought that was one of the defining
characteristics of the Jack Reacher okay
yeah Jack reachers and he's I read it
for him basically he's basically [ __ ]
Batman he's supposed to be six six and
[ __ ] yeah and dude it just [ __ ]
chokes your [ __ ] head off you know
what I mean and this is not you know Tom
Cruise is not that Tom Cruise is five
six and well they made a series with a
much bigger dude that is more like that
yeah
so he's miscast sometimes but he does do
a good job in everything that they put
him in and I heard that the [ __ ]
Maverick is supposed to be real good it
should be coming out soon all right yeah
we still haven't seen it supposed to be
real good if you probably should have
seen it on the big screen but it will
yeah
if it's good I'll buy it if it's good
I'll support it oh see Zach was saying
actually an all women Expendables with
some crotchety older action chicks
sounds like a lot of fun it does I would
I would probably totally watch that yeah
I would uh and I would have uh Stallone
do that produce it and maybe even direct
it maybe not in it but then you could
cross them over
where the Expendables yeah you'd have
like an extended you know right that's
how I would do that yeah evidently he
just came out with something new it's
supposed to be really good little swole
said man you guys see the new movie it's
good
oh that's right what the [ __ ] was the
name of that thing he said it was good I
remember him sending us a message yeah
he said this is a good movie you'll like
it
[ __ ] look man loves all the action
yeah so that's what they always like
every time he sees a good one he always
moves such as Tom and said oh you gotta
watch it yeah yeah he loves all the old
even though he's a lot younger than us
he's really into like all this 80s like
action Stars yeah little little swallows
my [ __ ] um my retro connection
we came up into bars together
although he's not young anymore I think
he's pushing 40 now in he well I'm just
saying he's a lot younger than us than
we are yeah but um
he's uh he told me about the
what was what was what was the [ __ ]
Sly uh [ __ ] superhero one that
[ __ ] came out for free that was
pretty good too yeah just a couple
months back what was it called uh I
can't remember
um it was all right it was all right it
was good these are good for [ __ ] the
budgets that he did you know those are
not big budget boobies they're they're
[ __ ] basically I think they're
independent flicks really I think he's
produced himself I think he does a good
job I mean when you got money like that
like he's got you can kind of do what
you want
I know a lot of you guys listen and
we're the same generation as me and
we've watched we watched to the [ __ ]
Clash of the Titans between [ __ ]
Arnold Schwarzenegger and [ __ ]
Sylvester Stallone who is the best and
uh
it's clear to me now that [ __ ]
Sylvester Stallone [ __ ] well like I
said because he was kind of the whole
package I mean he could actually act he
can write he could write he can produce
he can direct he Stills [ __ ] looks
great I mean you guys want to know how
to age look at [ __ ] Sylvester
Stallone that dude about 75. he's
[ __ ] looking good for 70. they're in
I mean this he's that's like top one
half percent of the male population
smaller than a half a percentage look
that good at 75 years old yeah with John
he's on wife number seven I think his
new wife is just being born now oh no
[ __ ] every time he gets married she's
younger and younger and younger and
younger I mean every time he gets
married his new wife gets born somewhere
yeah he gets married and another wife's
born he's like okay I'll get you in a
bit and then he like okay yeah he puts a
hold on right and while she's still a
baby produced he's produced he's
produced and created so many beautiful
young women in his life every one of his
daughters is a [ __ ] knockout
have you ever you've seen his daughters
well I saw that one that was in that
movie every one of his daughters is cute
how is that specific enough for you yeah
I saw that one that was in that movie
yeah I think my name is Celeste alone
was it was it the shark movie was it the
shark the shark movie yeah she was in
there she was good in it she was another
shark she didn't really stand out but
you know that's 47 meters down the
second one yeah the second one Unchained
or unusual you really stand out but I
think that might have been a good thing
because she didn't stand out as bad if
you stand out as bad then that's bad she
just fit right in with the tone of the
movie yeah yeah
yeah I mean really
for an actor like especially if you're
just starting out and you know not to be
mean but if you're not like that great
an actor like the best you can hope for
is just to like not just to kind of not
to stand out as such just to kind of
stay in the background yeah don't don't
stand out for being like super like
worse than everybody else right Richard
Brown said is Rosemary's Baby a female
horror film
um no I think I would just call that
well see that's the problem that you get
into because I kind of feel like for me
like a horror movie is just a horror
movie like if it's a male female or a
male character main character or female
main character or whatever it doesn't
really matter to me I'm just kind of
like interested in what the story is and
like you know is this a good movie or
not and I think that sometimes you can
get too wrapped up in oh this is like a
female-centered horror movie or this is
I mean yeah it's about a woman and it's
about how she gets [ __ ] gaslighted
and [ __ ] like that but
I don't think that necessarily makes it
because it doesn't matter like
it doesn't really matter what the what
the gender of the main character is like
everyone can experience that not
pregnancy obviously but the same kind of
thing like being told that you're crazy
and all that other kind of stuff like it
doesn't necessarily have to be a woman
so I don't know
I just I don't know I just like [ __ ]
story I just like good stories I don't
give a [ __ ] if it's men or women or
whoever
is at the center of it just tell me a
good story that entertains me that's all
I ask for it's not a lot really all
right there's a bunch of people talking
to me go ahead and read them off Jen
they're talking oh wait I got way behind
all right yeah well I got way behind
because I like talking all right we got
a big crowd in there for our show Tom
Sykes said some say net of the comet is
the greatest film with two broads as the
leading roles and so do I we still
haven't done it I mean I kind of feel
like I don't know if we're going to
because yeah because our next matinee
show is Sunday which is Christmas day so
I don't know if we're actually gonna do
something on Christmas day maybe we will
maybe we'll be bored and we'll like come
on and do it maybe we'll do night of the
comment I don't know because I keep we
keep promising we're gonna do it and
it's like I just haven't got around to
doing it
um
Ben said wasn't Coyote Ugly a practical
joke to get guys to watch a chick flick
was it a chick flick
okay I don't I'm pretty sure I saw it
but I don't remember a single [ __ ]
thing about it
I don't remember a single thing about it
um
yeah John Smith Tom Cruise is amazing in
Interview with the Vampire yeah I didn't
think I was gonna like him in that but
he was actually good in that but it's
because he's playing kind of a dick
whenever he's playing kind of a dick
he's good because he doesn't really have
to stretch all that much I mean you know
that's kind of my opinion anyway
uh let's see that's what people said
around yeah the Jack Reacher TV show
much closer to the source material we
should probably get around to watching
that because we were talking about that
when we were talking about the Jack
Reacher movie yeah that they had made
the series with that like bigger dude
grampers says best Christmas TV event
ever was the 1978 Star Wars holiday
special where our Rogue Heroes went to
Chewbacca's house and enjoyed YouTube
yeah Yuletide by the Chewie's wife it's
on YouTube yeah and they're puppy
children Christmas yeah it's um it's
really something it looks like there's
still probably like a lot of drugs
involved yeah it's hot they're high but
uh it's it's been restored and
everything
the cross of the Christmas special even
had no [ __ ] mod or what's the name
[ __ ]
woman a chick that played mod [ __ ]
sings B Arthur B Arthur she she [ __ ]
plays since the song in it
some of that stuff that came out in the
70s man it's like you watch it now and
I'm just like what the [ __ ] were they
thinking cocaine that's what they were
thinking they just had to get some Star
Wars eyes on this on the foot because
they wanted some Star Wars money and
they just cooked that up real quick
and they this is before V8 VCRs and VHS
so there's no way people could record it
really they thought it would be one and
done no one would ever see it again
that's what that's little did they know
little did they know
that somebody saved that [ __ ]
they could not foresee YouTube
well yeah
I feel like I just got a hair from my
wig like in my mouth and I can't get it
out
well see that's the thing it's like
nobody really
nobody that was making stuff in the 60s
and 70s and you know you can't blame
them but they couldn't foresee
that there would be this massive
you know pool of like collectors and
also people that were really really into
Retro [ __ ] that were really into all
that stuff yeah it was so disposable
[ __ ] it was supposed to just comment
yeah well I was when I was researching
my um video that I'm gonna put up
tomorrow about all the rank and bass
like the stop-motion uh Christmas
specials that they did like Rudolph the
Red-Nosed Reindeer and Santa Claus is
coming to town and stuff and the thing
about it is that when they did the the
animation with the puppets nobody
thought to like keep the puppets yeah
you know what I mean because they were
just kind of like oh well we're done and
we're just like yeah they just threw
them out or they just like took them
home for their kids to play with or some
[ __ ] like that so they most of them just
got lost or like busted up or whatever
and so they didn't realize back in the
1960s that 50 years later people would
still be talking about that [ __ ] no it
was just about it was an industry where
you just made up some [ __ ] real quick
you put it on there you [ __ ] sold
advertising for it advertising spots on
it and then it was gone you didn't and
then you moved on to the next thing
there's no no concept of collector's SEC
or secondary Market or classic or it was
disposable disposable and that was the
Star Wars uh holiday uh [ __ ] show was
disposable I remember waiting for it to
come on I sat there and watched it
[ __ ] when they come out I was like oh
oh I was freaking out the whole time
I loved it and they're singing and
[ __ ] he's watching [ __ ] Wookie
porn and [ __ ] you know remember that
that's right there was looking forward
I forgot who it was it was a pretty
black singer uh who did the [ __ ] song
that's right who the [ __ ] was that in
that it wasn't Eartha Kitt was it no she
was real big in the 70s real big in the
70s they had her in like damn it I know
who it is and now I can't remember the
leotard I know who it was at the time
because she was on the radio yeah yeah
my mom would be listening to a new so it
was real um relevant to the 70s
so it's weirder now because you don't
because all of it yeah it's all gone and
people aren't connected to the culture
but
in the 70s that was not weird at all it
was just it was very like contemporary
real hit like oh yeah yeah it'd be like
having [ __ ] you know uh some stars on
there today it'd be like having [ __ ]
I don't know
who's big now you know somebody don't
look at me I'm a big [ __ ] old [ __ ]
and we don't give a [ __ ] anyway I didn't
I didn't know who was famous like back
in the 80s when I was a teenager
I didn't know that yeah so I really
don't know now
I mean unless it's kind of like relevant
to my interests like you know in that
case like I know about it then but it's
like it's like I don't even know I don't
even know what mainstream culture is or
like what's popular Chewbacca's dad or
Granddad he was watching The Wookie porn
through the View-Master
see they had even they had even
predicted VR virtual reality see they
did he put the goggles on it was
was uh it wasn't Gladys it wasn't Gladys
Knights was it
oh maybe it was hold on God damn it who
the [ __ ] was it it was if it wasn't her
it was somebody like that yeah something
like that and he's watching her and
she's singing This Love Song and dancing
and but it made sense at the time and
Grandpa Wookie was like jerking it right
there in the league [ __ ] he's hiding it
from his wife and [ __ ] [ __ ] putting
it on again it was it was just a fun
show and this [ __ ] Han Solo shows up
and then for you and you lose it you
know you're a kid You're Gonna Lose
because you don't think you're another
move you don't think another movie's
gonna happen
you didn't know [ __ ] Empire Strikes
Back was coming you know yeah nothing
was guaranteed back then and then uh
[ __ ] Luke shows up and not even think
I even think Carrie a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Princess Leia yeah they didn't carry
Fisher show I think she's in it too yeah
she was able to yeah and they got the
little bit of the bar like a bar and
they're trying to [ __ ] it's like the
Cantina on Tatooine but it's not I mean
they kind they tried it was just like
yeah and like you said it was probably
less weird and like less jarring back
then because
it's funny because when you said about
seeing it in the context of the time
when stuff that was really big at the
time that isn't big or people have
forgotten about nowadays I kind of feel
like when I was doing for my other
channel
I was talking about The Addams Family
Halloween special which I think came out
in 1978 I wanted to say and you know
that was many many years like after The
Adams Family Show had gone off the air
but they all like looked pretty much the
same and I've noticed in there that they
made like a whole bunch of cultural
references that I don't think most
people that aren't old like me would
know what they were talking about like
they made a joke about
um Mikey and how he likes it you know
what I mean yeah which remember that
Life cereal commercial which was huge
yeah he'll try anything in the [ __ ]
70s like you know hey Mikey you know
what I mean so it's like they made a
joke like that and I said like if
younger people were watching that
nowadays they would know have no idea
like why that was funny well it wasn't
funny but I'm just saying why they
thought it would be funny because they
were referencing something that was like
really popular at the time but it was a
commercial yeah so
but I kind of feel like it's one of
those commercials like [ __ ] where's
the beef in the 80s which was like
massive and everybody yeah like talking
about like mac tonight
I remember that yeah okay so I remember
that we're getting sidetracked go ahead
well yeah that's what we got that's what
this show is but the thing about Mac
tonight though is that I know it's from
McDonald's I know that but what exactly
was that promoting
yeah it was a new it was a new menu that
they were trying to promote right they
were trying to make McDonald's more
classy
before classy before McDonald's got
people in there by selling kid mckitty
meals and giving away free toys yeah so
it's the kids pulling the it's the kids
pulling the adults into the [ __ ] to
buy something from McDonald's
they reversed it they tried to get it to
to make it so it was a place that would
attract adults so they went with a
nightclub the theme they got rid of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] Ronald McDonald looking stuff
and they brought in this [ __ ] dude
that looked like a damn Moon his whole
head looked like a moon
I liked that character I liked that
whole like uh campaign though I thought
it was kind of it didn't go on for very
long it didn't but I remember the DLT
and they had a couple of other things
that they were saying yeah and they kind
of changed the decor of all the the uh
the McDonald's classing up the joints
yeah
all right so uh okay so I'm yeah I
missed a bunch of stuff John Smith said
Carrie Fisher later said she was high as
a kite during the making of the holiday
special I kind of feel like Carrie
Fisher was high because uh all the time
like during that time period as well
she'd be the first to admit that yeah
well not anymore because she's she died
but you know what I mean but back then
she would have uh Ben said if you
remember the 70s you weren't doing it
right
Kevin Smith says Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas to you as well John Smith said
fun Christmas fact all of Santa's
reindeer including Rudolph are female
which is interesting because the
specials that I was doing they did
actually pause it in uh
uh The Year Without a Santa Claus that
Vixen was female however I will say that
in the Rudolph special Rudolph is very
clearly male and his dad is Donner so
that he's obviously male also I thought
it was very funny too that Rudolph's mom
was named Mrs Donner she didn't even
have her own name she was just Mrs
Donner I thought that's because they
made that up I thought well I know that
I just thought that was like really
funny they didn't even like give her a
name
it's just like I didn't want to make her
a vixen
[Laughter]
well they could have given her I mean
there was another porn star name there
was another yeah uh you know there were
other uh reindeer in there that had
other names like there was Clarice and
there was Fireball and there was like so
there was other reindeer that had other
names they could have given her a name
but they didn't
uh let's see Diane Carroll was that who
it was that was dancing maybe I don't
know yeah we have to look at this it's
been so long
yeah I haven't seen it for a reason
somebody who was famous back then yeah
and and she actually had some hit songs
that if I heard him I'd recognize them
but I can't put a name to it
grafter said the 70s was a crazy time
polyester shirts Bell Bottom Jeans
cocaine random sex El Caminos serial
killers would have at least 20 victims
yeah and people would pay money for a
pet rock that about sums it up doesn't
it that about sums it up
no it wasn't Aretha Franklin no Aretha
Franklin was too old it might have been
Diane Carroll or like you said Gladys
Knight although it was Gladys Knight how
old was she in that in when did that
come out 77 yeah it
um from what I remember the woman
singing was in her late 30s around 30s I
would think I would say
Ben said the Stormtroopers show up and
Bully Chewbacca Chewbacca's son yeah and
break his toy it traumatized me as a
child that led me to a lifelong distrust
of Stormtroopers I I [ __ ] I lost it
when the Stormtrooper showed up I love
seeing those things I wasn't quite I
never could quite remember what they
looked like at that era so every time
I'd see one I go yeah that's it that's
that's it and now it's you know you know
exactly what Stormtrooper looks like
it's just so weird to think back at that
time period because it's like yeah if
you didn't see the movie back then it's
not like you could just like go on the
internet and like look at a picture of
it right and then like the little action
figure little things that they'd say so
you didn't quite they weren't quite
accurate you and you did see some
photographs like they'd have photographs
and magazines
but seeing a move on a screen you know
what I mean from all angles it just it
was just better
yeah you're like yeah like I for a long
time
I was trying to figure out what the
alien looked like from Alien one
you know yeah because to be fair they
didn't know it well they didn't show it
like real well in their first movie like
you couldn't see it like in all its
Glory yeah I wasn't quite sure what it
looked like
Jasmine said the reindeer must be female
as they all have their antlers at
Christmas time only female reindeer keep
antlers this time of year so there you
go that's that's a fun fact and like I
said
even though Vixen was female in the one
of the specials but Rudolph and Donna at
least were male in the first one so they
[ __ ] that up
um Tom Sykes said the Little Drummer Boy
rank in a bass film was the worst out of
all the films I didn't actually review
that one because I was gonna just do the
stop motion because I know they did
Frosty the Snowman and the stingiest man
in the world or whatever it was the one
that was um you know Based On A
Christmas Carol and I liked those as
well but I was like well [ __ ] I can't
like I don't have time to watch all of
these so I just want to do like the
three main
um you know stop-motion ones but yeah
they did do the Little Drummer Boy but
see I saw that when I was a kid and I
said this in the video I saw that when I
was a kid but um I remember that one not
sticking with these much because it was
like jesusy yeah because it was about a
kid that was going to see like Jesus
being born yeah you know how far behind
are we on these uh I think I'm caught up
unless I missed a bunch yeah you skipped
a bunch of questions people had asked
well what were they
um I mean you can see them yeah like you
know which ones you want to answer
Jenny will skip a question put to me she
doesn't really no I did well sometimes I
don't see them because like sometimes it
just kind of goes up and down I'm not
doing it on purpose like just to be mean
to you or something
got to go
I don't know all right Tom said uh did
Tom and Jenny see the Halloween ends oh
Halloween ends we did not see that okay
we saw Halloween kills which was
actually pretty good yeah but we haven't
got around to Halloween ads yet John
Smith said yeah the Star Wars disco
theme is on YouTube too okay so I'm
gonna have to look that up later yeah
I didn't like disco at the time but it's
kind of like grown on me over the years
gonna say
I guess because I'm so far removed from
it now yeah it's like it's okay there's
one Tom Sykes says Tom watch
the Tom Cruise film Edge of Tomorrow
did you see that nope didn't see it just
like aliens it's sort of but better I
haven't seen that one Edge of Tomorrow
okay I'll watch it
I've heard of that I thought we had seen
it but maybe not maybe I'm confusing it
with something else
then and then Tammy's talking about the
stop was supposed to be over six feet
tall yeah he was and he was supposed to
be 16 I think when he was I thought he
was 18 but still something like if
you're really young yeah yeah when he
got turned so really young
would look kind of funny
I mean he yeah he was good in that I'm
not saying that but I don't know I still
I still wonder what that movie would
have been like with someone else in it
yeah Ben came Ben Freo came in and said
demolition man's one of the best great
Sci-Fi movies all time yes one of the
greatest and a [ __ ] it all came true
Demolition Man came true you know why
don't you put the uh uh well because you
got questions okay let me see
this you were complaining you were
behind so yeah you can get caught
all right
there was something else somebody had
asked me
where'd that go
[ __ ] where'd that question go
trying to remember
all right somebody asked me a question
and I can't find it
um
if you asked me a question I didn't
answer it you can drop it back down in
the comment section again
and I'll answer it but I I forgot where
it was
I can't find it I forgot what the damn
question was
yeah I can't find it
I don't remember where it was
I don't remember what it was yeah I
can't find it somebody to ask me a
question and I can't find it maybe I
already like said it not paying
attention
Tom Sykes said it's like aliens means
Groundhog Day what the hell is that mean
Edge of Tomorrow okay there must be some
time Loops or something yeah I guess so
Hugo says Friday the 13th part 3D has a
disco version
Lake that's authorized or no
because I'm kind of intrigued either way
Ben says one of the few episodes I saw
of That 70s Show the guy told his
girlfriend when they were debating what
to do that weekend we can have sex
anytime this is Star Wars
[Laughter]
pretty much
and let's see
William Shatner did that mystery program
what's going to do a bunch of those well
um we watched that one that he did
called The Unexplained
which they have on is it on um Amazon
Prime I don't know it's recent like it
was only it's only like a year or two
yeah I think it was Amazon and I think
there's like two or three seasons of it
it's actually like really good every
single show like they just do a handful
of different like hey this one's out of
about out of body experiences or this
one's about
um like mummies or this one you know
what I mean so it's actually like pretty
good and he's like really Hamming it up
in there well
he's always handled up but you know what
I mean he's doing like the Shatner stick
which is what you pay him for but I
really like that show although he denies
it being a shake
well I mean I don't I don't mean that in
a disparaging way it's just that's maybe
that's just the way he's like you know
what I mean that's what he's like yeah
he he denies he if you say you do the
shadow thing I'm not doing the shattered
thing he's like I'm just me I'm just
being me
just me is that that's the shatter thing
that would be like I don't know maybe
maybe he thinks of it as like that'd be
like people saying that like I was doing
a shake and I'm just like no I'm just
like anything I'm just like doing like
what I normally do I even do I even do
that like when I'm watching a movie in
here by myself and like no one's around
like get out of me I would like talk to
the [ __ ] movie just like I'm talking
to you guys uh John Smith said didn't uh
Leonard Nimoy do a mystery type show yes
he did it was called in search of and
it's great I loved that show when I was
growing up so so creepy like I kind of
feel like everything about it
um you know it's probably like dated
nowadays but
I don't know there was something about
it like back then like watching it in
the 70s and because it was Leonard Nimoy
and I always Associated him with Spock
so he always was very like authoritative
so you could like believe some [ __ ] like
if he told you that this [ __ ] happened
like on the show you know what I mean
like if this [ __ ] was creepy then
Spock says it's Spock approved you know
what I mean it's like so I used to like
really love that [ __ ] I used to love
that [ __ ]
Zach says got something for Tom was
looking at movies shot in Indiana and
one is an 80s porn action movie about
college girls who get raped and then go
after their attackers with machine guns
that sounds pretty fun actually I
wouldn't mind seeing that
is there going to be a show on Sunday we
might do one I'm not really sure
we might do like a Christmas horror
movie or something like that we'll see I
mean
it'll depend yeah we're gonna do like
Christmas and we're gonna do like a
Christmas dinner but we usually have
that earlier
so I don't know like if we're bored
after where do we might Maybe
unless we're like drunk already
we'll see I'll post about it and like
see what happens and I might put up a
video too because I've been trying to
like put up videos like I said I was
trying to get the one about the rank and
bass specials I was trying to get that
one put up today but I only just
finished editing it like before we
started doing this show thank you
grampers grafter says if y'all like the
13 o'clock podcast give a buck or two if
you have a buck or two yes thank you
very much we would very much appreciate
that but yeah so I was gonna get it put
up today but
I only just finished editing it and I
didn't finish the thumbnail image yet
and I want to have time to kind of like
work on that so I'll probably wait till
tomorrow to put it up but I don't know I
wanted to at least get
another Christmas horror movie and maybe
that I have like a book of Christmas
horror stories that I wanted to read and
review I'll see if I have time
we might do die in the comet because I
know I felt bad because like a lot of
people have requested that and I feel
bad that we haven't got around to it yet
so maybe we'll do that maybe we'll watch
that Saturday night and we'll talk about
it Sunday
I said they were asking if we were going
to do a stream on Sunday which is
Christmas day oh okay and I said maybe
maybe we'll see everybody's asking us to
unite to the comic because that's like a
Christmas horror movie okay so maybe
we'll do that maybe I don't want to see
I want to see that and I want to see
that uh Tom Cruise uh
yeah yeah I've heard of that it's like I
can't believe that we haven't seen that
I like Oblivion I did too
well let me write it down like right
edge of tomorrow so we can remember
maybe we can watch it later you won't
remember write it down well I'll just
remember it's a Tom Cruise [ __ ]
science fiction movie okay I'll find it
it's probably on it's probably on Amazon
I'd imagine probably see it for free
probably what time is it
7 30. okay it's early still
yeah it's early so you get some heat
though
which what do you what are you thinking
I got that pork tenderloin already
uh maybe uh want some Ramen with that oh
sound good
Diamond Tree I can make you cheese Ramen
you like do you want that cheese in it
um no cheese in it I can um you just
want to regular Ramen with that and some
vegetables yeah I like vegetables okay I
don't like all that cheese you got beef
Ramen
I do you have beef or you have chicken
they uh honestly they all taste pretty
much the same to you
they all taste like salty
Thompson creamer in it uh sure okay a
lot of people like cream roots and
creamer is really good yeah it like
thickens it up yeah
Tom Sykes said the David Hess 1980
slasher flick to all a good night is an
underrated Christmas horror film also
free on YouTube might check that one out
too because I really like David Hess you
know what's interesting is that what was
the last Quentin Tarantino movie we did
hateful eight right yeah that had a
David Hess song in it and it was the one
that was in Last House on the Left it
was hateful eight I think that had that
song in it right yeah so see [ __ ]
Tarantino he's getting like
down deep he's gonna like doing the Deep
Cuts man because as soon as I heard that
I was just kind of like oh my God that's
[ __ ] that's David S he was in Last
House on the Left he played Krug like
the main rapist guy
he was he always played characters like
that I guess because of what he looked
like
Tom psych said Friday the 13th one
ripped off to all a good night kind of
I kind of feel like the Friday the 13th
movies as much as I love them they did
kind of like rip off a lot of things
didn't they
Friday the 13th was basically I mean
they basically made that as Sean
Cunningham saying hey let's rip off
Halloween yeah Friday the 13th part two
straight up stole two whole entire
scenes from Mario Baba's twitch of the
death nerve AKA Bay of blood like
including that spear through the couple
that were that was stolen right from Bay
of blood that was the exact same scene
they even shot at the same and
everything
it was homaging you know so much you got
to put it back in the time the day that
it came out
I was there is a damn
YouTube channel of these guys they're
younger than me now
um but in the very late 80s they got
their hands on a video
camcorder
back when they were you could get one
all of a sudden for 250 300 dollars
because before then there were thousands
of dollars I remember when that [ __ ]
happened yeah they were very expensive
and overnight like in the very late 80s
you could get one for about 300 bucks
and it was like what well these kids got
their when they were still in I mean
they're like [ __ ] 15 16 years old
they got their hands on this [ __ ]
camera and they're they're growing up in
Alabama
when I was a metal head and the other
ones it's like almost like Bill and Ted
and they took all these videos of them
when they were kids talking about their
air guitar band and going around their
town and they've posted up all their
[ __ ] videos from when they were a kid
and they're they made movies and
everything it's [ __ ] hilarious that's
so cool and it's getting hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of views well yeah
people love that [ __ ] yeah and then
young people are like tripping out about
how we grew up they're like man I wish I
grew up in the late 80s the 80s was so
great
uh certain parts of it was good some of
it was okay some of it was I wouldn't go
back though no thanks yeah I would go
back for certain things certain things
were really good back then but uh no
and it's funny to see
things to go back and see things in the
context of the time yeah they go to uh
they're in Alabama I'm trying to
remember [ __ ] what the name of this
channel is I can refer you guys to it
I'll get to it when I after I tell a
story I'll go in there and I'll try to
find it and I'll tell you and I'll show
you guys you guys will get a kick out of
me
they go to a used record store
in their little town in Alabama all
right and it's just all making sense to
me you know kind of growing up for most
of the Summers of my early life going in
Mississippi to see my dad
because Mississippi and Alabama is not a
spitted difference between them they
were the same state at one time it was
all Alabama and then Mississippi split
off or it was all Mississippi and
Alabama split off I don't remember
exactly how it went
but um they go to this little
used record store and you can get a
record for two dollars oh
and they're dudes got long hair and he's
like trying to be as cool as he could
possibly be he's 15 and he goes if any
and he's talking to the camera as if
he's talking to the [ __ ] live TV all
right and if they're they're recording
this [ __ ] on a VHS tape all right
there's no distribution you're right and
he goes and if any of you girls are out
there you know you come see us come see
me come to you know this is where we are
because if you're 14 or if you if you
because if you're 14 or or older you can
come see me if you're 14 or younger you
can come see me [ __ ] but I but you
can't be a little kid
and it's so women he says if you're 14
or older you could come and see if
you're 14 and younger you can come and
see me
no babies though no babies yeah he says
you can come and see him you know it's
just [ __ ] if you can walk you can
because he is and then I was just like I
know where you're coming from they warn
neighborhoods about dudes yeah
he's 14. oh okay so he's 14. you should
have like said that up front no I was
imagining no I was imagining I thought
that you said that they were
interviewing somebody I thought okay no
they got a camera and it's kids running
around the camera but you said that they
went in a used record store I assumed
that you were that they were
interviewing the person that owned or
worked at the restaurant so I was
assuming that it was no and 18 and up no
they were talking to each other as they
were walking with the camera all right
so they go to [ __ ] they go to the so
that's significantly less they're gonna
restore them buy candy and everything
okay he's got long hair and they got
homemade [ __ ] band shirts for their
air guitar band it's called it's it's
called it's plainly says macabre
all right that's the name of the band
they're calling it macabre
oh Macabre they're mispronouncing their
own [ __ ] band's name Macabre and
although and that actually would have
been funnier and clever cleverer if they
called it that but they spelled it like
m-a-k-a-b-r-a they're called it
that would be really fun yeah no he's
only 14. okay and he goes and he goes if
any of you girls out there want to come
see us [ __ ] and he gives this [ __ ]
address I think and he goes if you're 14
or older you can come to me he goes if
you're 14 and younger you can come see
us but you but you can't be a baby
basically
like I said no no infants they're not
good yeah so basically you can come and
see him well that's okay I'm gonna try
to find I can try to find what the name
you know what's funny though when you
said about Macabre was that I remember
um if any of you have read Stephen
King's uh dance Macabre you know uh the
the book where he talks about and he
talks about
um some of his like formative
experiences with horror like when he was
young and he was talking about there was
a movie that came out I can't remember
what year it came out I want to say it
was like the 60s but maybe it was
earlier and it was called Macabre and he
said that him and his little friends
because they were just kids they called
it mcbear that's him
oh look at that kid the name of the
channel is Eric and Daryl Eric and Daryl
Eric and Daryl Metalhead teens
19 1989. oh I remember that yeah that's
them
look at that and his mom's got the
vacuum cleaner running and they're gonna
go mom she's introducing the dog and
then they walk they walk they walk down
and get some candy and then they go to
the record store there's Mom Mom's tell
them they need to vacuum they're like oh
hell no and then they leave they're like
[ __ ] that
[ __ ] that and then [ __ ] you Mom we're
getting out of here
he's the one that says if you're over 14
you can see him if you're under 14 you
can come visit him and he's introducing
you to his whole [ __ ] neighborhood
in Alabama and then they go to the well
anyway
what was funny you know I was saying in
the context of everything
is that they go and
they go to the Chinese restaurant
but that they were going through their
used records and they found a
Queensryche album the warning
and it was so funny to see it was it was
old in in the late 80s probably about
four years old but it's just funny to
see it in the context
of [ __ ]
teenager that that's that's the record
store of teenagers in the 80s
it was funny because I was just
listening to that album and it brought
it back to me how old that is yeah
that was an old album it's right there
was that Frampton Comes Alive I thought
I saw Fred yeah it's right there
yeah Eric and Daryl Eric with a C
but they got a lot of good videos I'm
looking I'm trying to see the posters on
the wall but I can't really see and then
they still what happened to this kid
what happened if he became a lawyer
went to University became a lawyer yeah
he goes in there he finds he finds a
[ __ ] that's hilarious yeah that looks
like the record store that used to be in
uh Daytona yeah that was called criminal
records
or two
macabre
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are they
saying macabre
and they're talking about this band like
it's a [ __ ] band like a real band
they got their shirts and their [ __ ]
handmade shirts mcabri and then I saw it
and I go that's Makai oh my God
that's darling I love that I love that
it's like some [ __ ] a 14 year old would
come on it is exactly well it is yeah it
is I mean that's exactly what that's I
mean that's adorable that's adorable
Zach said I always wonder where you draw
the line between homage and ripoff
because I know when I'm working on
stories that they that they aren't
original enough and then I wind up never
finishing any of them yeah that's the
thing it's like really hard because
sometimes
I mean you get ideas from other stories
and movies and things like that but you
want to like at least change it enough
to I don't really have a problem with
homage as long as you're not
because you know I think we got into
this a little bit we were talking about
Quentin Tarantino because a lot of
people are just like oh he's just like
he's essentially like a collage artist
pretty much but the thing about it the
thing why I don't mind it when Tarantino
does it is because one he doesn't make
any [ __ ] secret about it right and he
you know he's basically like hey I got
this from that and this from that and
this from that yeah it's like homage
when they know that you know yeah and
it's a rip-off and he just loves the
[ __ ] so much that he's just trying to
and honestly like I think he's done a
great service to a lot of these more
obscure filmmakers who maybe people
would have forgotten about if he hadn't
homage them in one of his movies and
then everybody's like oh like you know
Quentin Tarantino talked about that so
I'm gonna go watch it so I think that he
in a lot of ways like he used his Fame
for good you know what I mean so I think
that's cool yeah [ __ ] Richard Brown
knows knows the warning album [ __ ]
warning album's good man warning album
came true basically about a One World
Government trying to take over and
people fighting it and it's but it's
kind of way in the future and they're
using they got a cyborgs and dudes
[ __ ] and putting chips in people's
heads and they're
they were they were they were Alex Jones
before Alex Jones man but they were
doing the fantasy it was like Star Wars
the thing is I never really could make
sense out of the [ __ ] story on the
album
turns out that the label made them
change the order of the songs
you can go on YouTube
and they've they've reshuffled the
original or the the the or the intended
order of those songs and it makes a lot
more sense it's a concept album it was
like an opera
because all their [ __ ] was Operation
mind crime and all that which that was a
good album too but I I liked the warning
you know I thought that that was
actually their first full-length album
Jeff Tate man the [ __ ] could
sing man [ __ ] almost like an opera
singer real good
e Perry III says random question for Tom
can you type up the name of the Aztec
drink you make the one with guava
yeah the cuckoo con you haven't made
that in a while in a while it only has
three ingredients it's basically like
it's a third tequila yeah and then one
third a third guava nectar yeah guava
nectar and then what's the third thing
um pineapple it was five I think it was
fine or mango no it was a mango
pineapple it's pineapple pineapple juice
or orange [ __ ] what was it I'm pretty
sure I wrote it down it was pineapple
pineapple and I was getting it I was
getting that from the international
aisle out of the damn grocery store when
you go right where the fuckogoya food is
and you keep going and then there's uh
like a um
Nicaraguan
and [ __ ] El Salvador and [ __ ]
Brands there and they'll have these
little cartons
of like uh two a one liter cartons of
juice they're like a DOT and those days
are like a dollar sixty they've like
doubled
but it was guava and pineapple yeah
guava pineapple and Tequila like equal
parts
yeah you'll like it it was Silver
Tequila
all right Silver Tequila is cheaper
that's like Mexican vodka all right
you're supposed to mix that you're not
supposed to be mixing gold or anyo angio
not supposed to be mixing that yeah it's
not yes that's drinking whiskey right
um you're really not supposed to be
mixing Reposado but I do too I I was it
was that was Hornitos what episode was
really good in that
even though you're paying extra money
to drink it straight you know silver is
meant to be mixed
but sometimes you just do what you want
to do like you don't use [ __ ] you don't
use scotch in a mixed drink you just
don't
well you don't use really good your
liquor in a you know I mean you use good
liquor but you don't use like really
really good expensive [ __ ] like you
don't make like a mixed drink with that
because like you want to just taste it
yeah you want to use kind of [ __ ]
middle of the road right
like this for example is what Skye this
guy this is that's middle of the road
vodka but that Sky's real good cheap
[ __ ] yeah it's like what is it 24.99 24
bucks for a big old thing Zach says also
can we talk about how cool it is you can
now shoot a movie on your phone and it
actually looks good yeah see everything
I think that's awesome I think like all
the um technology is so cheap because
like when we were growing up
um you know it was like [ __ ] hugely
if you wanted to like make movies or
something like that movie cameras all
like uh recording equipment like if you
wanted to be in a band or something like
that was hugely expensive so it was like
a massive outlay of money and it's like
and once you made something like you
didn't have distribution it's not like
you could just upload it and have like
millions of people see it yeah no you
just had a tape that's it yeah a way to
distribute it nope that's why I thought
there I thought [ __ ] what's what was
the name Eric and Daryl I thought they
were funny because they're making VHS
tapes and they're they're presenting
their materials as if the entire world
sees it nobody saw it well now they are
but we saw that [ __ ] until they were
[ __ ] grown men yeah until YouTube
happened yeah and they're on there they
got older and they're [ __ ] on there
and they made movies and
[ __ ] that metal head guy he's only in
some of them
metal head kid
and uh he turned out to be a lawyer
but the other guy and then they had
some of their girlfriends come over and
[ __ ] you know and it's so funny to
see a 14 year old boy looks like a child
a 14 year old girl looks like a [ __ ]
woman yeah they looked a little totally
yeah women generally like yeah it looked
totally different
and um they mature much quicker yeah
yeah and she's obviously ready for a
makeout section and the boys are just
not getting it you know what I mean
she's flirting with them you know and
they're well why do you think girls that
age find boys so frustrating you'll want
to like go out with older ones because
it's like dudes that are like they're
just so dense yeah he was so it's dude
they're all in the room with the camera
and [ __ ] you're like sending them all
kind of thing you might as well have
like [ __ ] some before a flag yeah
like they're not even like paying
attention they have no idea what you're
what you're doing yeah and they're
picking her up and [ __ ] doing Feats
of Strength and [ __ ] joking around
the same way we grew up [ __ ] in the
Summers [ __ ] me in Mississippi you
know I was making out with some of them
though I wasn't that that dense but
these kids were they were scared they
were scared yeah they were scared of her
but she's
she's the same age as them but it's just
funny she looks like five years older
you know well we discussed that when we
were talking about the original Karate
Kid movie yeah exactly how basically
like uh the two of them like well
Elizabeth Shoe and uh what's his name
that played Daniel
were the same age or pretty much the
same age but she looked about five years
older than yeah yeah
and like it seemed really weird like I
was always weirded out by that movie
like how much older she looked yeah even
though technically I know they were like
the same age but she's on the channel
her name's Carol Carol they never said
what happened to Carol but Carol's about
14 and I wonder if they get her
permission like to I'm sure they do yeah
they all know each other they're all
friends no nothing bad happened didn't
it she's just being 14. no I was just
one yeah I was just wondering if like
yeah if they asked her if she knows
about it yeah well what's funny is that
she [ __ ] the door busts open and
she's pushing the little kid the little
guy they're the same age but she's short
smaller than her and they're giggling
like crazy and she goes I'm gonna grab
your [ __ ] dick I'm gonna [ __ ] pull
that [ __ ] out and then they got that
[ __ ] they got it on camera and then it
gets all embarrassed I already said she
was gonna wrap it around I'm gonna wrap
it around a hairbrush
and then she's gonna wrap his dick
around her hairbrush and [ __ ] pull it
up oh my God that's awesome and then all
of a sudden she plays it off like she
didn't say that
as you guys have the mirror [ __ ] ties
her shirt up in a [ __ ] not like this
because I look so frumpy she's trying to
show [ __ ] midriff and [ __ ]
and she doesn't get the dudes are not
getting it they're scared to death of
this [ __ ] girl right I guess so yeah
and then they're joking and
just joking around she's definitely
ready to make out with the [ __ ]
little blonde guy
and he doesn't get it
oh well he doesn't get it no
maybe that's what they thought was so
funny about the videos like look how
[ __ ] clueless we were I mean I I hope
I hope that they're less clueless than
that no no no they're not grown men now
now that they're well that doesn't mean
anything
in their 40s
grown men in their late 40s or 40s mid
40s
and they put out videos commenting on
the old ones
and that they can't believe how many
[ __ ] hits they got some of that [ __ ]
was like coming up on like four hundred
thousand five hundred thousand [ __ ] I
believe it
because it shows
it shows the way we grew up
and you see we couldn't do it because
when we were that age video cameras were
still too expensive
yeah we didn't have a video camera until
I was like way older because they were
like we couldn't afford one I couldn't
afford a video camera until like 1990
when I was in the Army at the PX then
all of a sudden they went down to about
three times the 90s before we had one
yeah they went down about two two
between 250 and 300.
depending on what the brand was a
Samsung I think which was considered
like a cheap Korean brand or something
Samsung what the [ __ ] is that you know
what I mean in 1990 nobody knew what
Samsung was that [ __ ] [ __ ] showed a
gold star that was another one I was
gonna say gold star I kind of feel like
was the one that was the bottom of the
barrel yeah and then but I think gold
star ended up getting bought by Samsung
I think because Goldstone oh maybe it's
in the gold star I remember we had a
gold star camera and that thing wasn't
definitely a piece of [ __ ] yeah I had
both I had like not a not a video camera
but just like a regular yeah I think I
had a I think I had a gold star
video camera I think I think it was
under 300 I think it might have been
275. it was great great little camera I
remember my dad bought a video camera
like used I don't know how much he paid
for it though but I don't think we had
it until
I kind of feel like it was the early 90s
yeah
but I don't think we had anything in the
80s [ __ ] man even in the early 80s like
even VCRs were expensive
like some of them were like a grander or
more
so Jack's asking if I like YouTube I
liked early YouTube liked uh The Boy
album war was real good
um [ __ ] Joshua Tree was good yeah I
liked everything about up until Joshua
Tree which was what 87. although
um
[ __ ] Octon baby wasn't bad you had to
listen to it a couple times and then it
had it had some good [ __ ] on it but then
after that I
it just started to get become very
mainstream and kind of stale it started
to go the way of [ __ ]
um
uh not so much the police but uh what's
his name um
sting you know sting started to go very
mainstream he started to have a
you know an older female audience of
[ __ ] yoga practitioners or something
and yeah nobody wants that you know
I mean no disrespect to sting it's just
that wasn't his audience the [ __ ]
police were [ __ ] neither was I but I
think yeah to the police I loved the
police you can put the police on right
now [ __ ] any all of their albums yeah
I love others all of them I had a bunch
of them yeah I had a bunch of them
[ __ ] great band I loved all their
[ __ ]
I like some of I think I bought sting
solo stuff up until
I had dream of the Blue Turtle he had
good he had good solos I had that one
yeah
what was the one after that I can't
remember
he had good solo stuff but he did yeah
as it went on though he started to go
for an older
crowd and a more female crowd as he was
he started to become very up his own ass
kind of sound very uh snotty elevated
too [ __ ] spiritual he started he just
it went that way
well that's kind of like it's he he went
for like nowadays it's kind of like like
you said it's kind of like the yoga
Wellness kind of crowd and there's a
whole like sub genre of like Tick Tock
and all that kind of stuff that like of
women that are into that and it's just
like I can't stand any of that [ __ ] yeah
I can't stand any of that like oh I'm so
spiritual and like [ __ ] crystals and
smoothies and it's like I can't stand it
and you look at him and the sting don't
[ __ ] fool me and that's the kind of
Dude to come steal your wife or your
girlfriend
and to get and to take you take her to
some [ __ ] yoga [ __ ] thing right
and he takes his yoga pass off in the
Lotus position
without touching anything and then which
actually would be kind of impressive and
your girlfriend or your wife takes her
pants off and [ __ ] she sits in the
[ __ ] logo
and then some music is some incest
happens and [ __ ] and then like a half
but about a half hour later your
girlfriend slowly kind of climbs up up
on Bobo and [ __ ] starts straddling
his [ __ ] lingam
and then she penetrates inside the
[ __ ] yanny
and then there's like this tantric
[ __ ] combination of [ __ ] fluids
that [ __ ] go and he's [ __ ] your
girlfriend okay it's just he's just
gonna [ __ ] say it a different way
he's not gonna [ __ ] portray it as
what it was but we all know what it was
and then
and then then he's gonna send your
girlfriend back to you okay and she's
gonna show up late that day okay and
then pants and them yoga pants all right
well [ __ ] okay and she's gonna play it
off all right and that's the
spirituality the [ __ ] is staying is
bringing okay so I see right through it
do you know what every time you you kind
of tell that story about sting yeah it
reminds me I tell this story about
staying well I'm just saying I think
you've told it like one time before
because I think I've never told a story
because I think I'm telling stories
about sting as if they happen but go
ahead go ahead I'm just saying it
reminds me of uh the movie the hand
because her because yeah his wife that
that's what I've been around although
you got it although you can't blame her
though because Michael Kane in that
movie yeah is a douchebag yeah he well
he's got toxic masculinity right he
can't let go so his wife
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna go jump on his
head over here although the the yoga
instructor in that movie isn't like
doesn't look anywhere good as sting does
no he was a douche too
well yeah they were both different
flavors of douche yeah
they were different douche flavors yeah
33 flavors of douchebaskets douche skin
Robins yeah
oh [ __ ]
oh my God that's a new t-shirt right
there I just [ __ ] made that up
[ __ ] sting
um you know I like Sting though I like
but like I said I don't like anything
that
I don't know I did
I don't mean to Blake pick but it's just
kind of like any of that kind of I don't
know how it's going on nowadays but I
kind of feel like for a time it was that
Oprah crowd you know what I mean yeah
like it was just like super super
woman-y and we're gonna do like the
womany book club and like the Lifetime
movies and stuff see I don't I I hate
that [ __ ] I can't see Perry the third
just [ __ ] thinking Tammy because you
can't look it up he said the cookbook
yeah yeah the cookbook says Tom and
Jenny are the saviors of my long grading
commute so he must be in his car commute
or he's commuting on a train
probably driving
so that's what it's for man yeah
Oracle just got here Oracle just showing
up yeah hey what's up
we're talking about uh staying in like
um in him and his lingam going into
people's yeah yeah up in the Annie yeah
you gotta use Pro oh I'm mixing up sting
and Steven Seagal yeah yeah yeah
their terminology I apologize
hahaha
but yeah I gotta say that like some
YouTube songs Bono could [ __ ] the right
okay yeah you can't [ __ ] right off yeah
yeah [ __ ] bottle
yes another sanctimony is [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah it's you know just play music and
the thing about it it's like the music
is shut the [ __ ] up well hey man he made
a lot of money laundering money
basically the thing about it is he's a
money launderer that's what he does I do
not I absolutely do not have a problem
with
let's go like celebrities or whoever
like look if they have a particular
cause or they have something they feel
passionate about I don't really have a
problem with them like talking about it
because well they're well well that's
was it I haven't gone to the end of what
I was gonna say there
you know I don't have a problem with
that because like hey they're a person
and they're entitled to have an opinion
just like every other brand of
[ __ ] is right so just because
they're famous and have money that's
doesn't make them any different
necessarily
but I'm just kind of feeling like if
the thing about Bono and maybe staying
to a lesser extent although I don't see
it as much with sting but I guess he's
kind of like that too but I'm kind of
like look if you feel passionately about
something and you have a [ __ ] ton of
money just give to that charity like you
can use your celebrity to like bring
attention to that everything but the
problem arises when they come out and
like get like you said sanctimonious
about it like they're kind of like
giving the impression that they're like
better than everybody or something like
that I don't have a problem with them
like bringing attention to an issue that
they are passionate about or they're
giving money to I don't have an issue
with that the thing is though is that
they're not giving money to those causes
well I'm just saying I don't have a
problem with them if they're actually
doing that yeah they're not actually
doing that I think what happened was
with Bono and maybe there's certain
aesthetic sting is they had this big
concert when we were a kid it was called
Live Aid yeah yeah remember to head that
live yeah 85 that was and then they have
won a lot of it and then they had
another one where they raised a bunch of
money and a couple of those dudes bottle
beer one of them realized you could you
could steal a lot of money through
charities
then all of a sudden they became charity
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you only have to give like one percent
of the money that you raise to this
supposed cause
I saw some [ __ ] where they actually
tracked how much money Bono got for
raising that money and how much actually
went to this [ __ ] African countries
basically nothing went to those African
countries it all went to him and his
friends and [ __ ] backers and it's
corrupt that's another thing it's like
it's money laundry about it it doesn't
be shitty about it right and and it's a
money laundering operation you got
crooked friends that need to launder
money so you put it into this charity to
[ __ ] launder it and then you send it
back to them through the [ __ ] back
door or turn it into tax write-offs
there's all kinds of things with their
lawyers that they can do it's all it was
all a [ __ ] scab
little starving kids in Africa didn't
get any of that money they'd raised
[ __ ] hundreds of millions of dollars
and maybe the 100 000 would show up over
there you know it was a joke
yeah John Smith said Bono complains
about rich people's greed but never paid
a penny in tax yeah that's another thing
and those dudes [ __ ] own [ __ ]
Mansions all over the [ __ ] world and
Yachts and [ __ ] they're just [ __ ]
filthy rich
I don't know if there's rich as they
used to be because a lot of those guys a
lot of those types of guys blow through
money quickly you know but which is
probably why they need to keep making
yeah because to be honest I can't even
imagine like being as rich as Bono I
don't even like it's like how the [ __ ]
would you have enough hours in the day
to like even spend that yeah they I'm
gonna say that look there are some cool
ways to [ __ ] grift money and to be a
crook all right
uh and and why you're a star and the
king of those [ __ ] was David
[ __ ] Bowie okay he got involved
in two of the most corrupt [ __ ]
businesses you could art art is all
about money laundering okay and [ __ ]
real estate okay but he was an honest
crook he's helping his friends with the
[ __ ] money laundering and [ __ ]
buying properties that's just the way
you do it you know well and he wasn't
like he's not telling everybody he's a
Sanctus right right right that's what I
mean he wasn't like he didn't have any
Illusions about coming out and saying oh
I'm giving all this money to like
starving right no anything like that
yeah that's where the problem is
art galleries are more about laundering
money I mean if he just like says hey I
invest in art and real estate yeah
that's what he's doing I mean
essentially so it's just like No One's
Gonna he's not like lying not lying
about is what he's doing about what he's
doing so in my mind I didn't never I
don't know Bowie I just know his work
and I [ __ ] measure him as a man I
think he was a good man uh and I think
he's an excellent businessman and
everybody said he was very Charming he
was good to have around
he was at for in his day he was
evidently the the most wealthy
musical performer
I think he was for most of them I mean
he might have been second to like Paul
McCartney or somebody like that but he
was definitely up there the most he was
supposed to be the most the thing is is
you got to look at the fine print his
money was not made in music
the music ended up being basically a
side project that was like his vanity
project eventually the money was all
being made in real estate
and uh
he was evidently the richest one and
Michael Jackson underneath him but under
a different definition Michael Jackson's
money was actually coming from record
sales and tourings so it's very
different not Bowie Bowie was coming
from Real Estate he was [ __ ] Rich
very rich
Bowie Bowie was a gangster basically
basically he's a gangster that's [ __ ]
awesome when you think of it that way
okay
and I imagine he had really good legal
teams to help him to invest he had to do
all this usually these guys don't do it
themselves per se they have a good team
you know firms
help them show what to do with their
money and to make decisions so they just
keep running it and running it and
running he had a lot of money
he owned a lot of a lot of properties at
one time but he was sold a lot of
properties too
and a lot of it had to do with Better
Homes and Gardens
a lot of people don't know this but he
he had his tentacles in this into
different parts of the media and he had
friends that ran Better Homes and
Gardens so they'd do these big [ __ ]
layouts on these [ __ ] exotic homes
down in Borneo on these islands and [ __ ]
little did they know that was David
Bowie's house
you know he was one of his he was on
yeah and it would be all kinds of
Kickbacks and
for a while [ __ ] Better Homes and
Gardens its job was to sell David
Bowie's real estates
that's power okay yeah that's power
and he knew how to play the cards he was
the gayest straight man in the [ __ ]
world all right
he was straight he was a closeted
heterosexual
but he got to the [ __ ] Top by having
so many gay friends that were [ __ ]
liked his music and his product and he
knew how to charm very wealthy
um gay men you know and
that's where it's began and it
snowballed from that you know I mean
which I can understand it if you're a
rich gay guy and you like David Bowie's
music you want that to go more
mainstream you're going to help fund
these projects to bring this you know to
fruition and then it starts snowballing
you know some people have called that
like the gay Mafia which I'm sure that
exists I know that exists there's like a
game off you but that's just things that
just look like mafia's when you have
scenes and people [ __ ] helping and
you know yeah that it kind of gives you
a certain like uh thing to say Mafia
no it's just like a bunch of people that
know each other it's like a scene like
right which there's nothing nefarious
about right necessarily and he was in
the day they would say you know well
that was kind of gay you know nowadays
he was more kind of like you would call
like gender non-binary or gender
bending what would be gender fluid
gender fluid that's that's Prague but he
was like a gender fluid
that's what you'd call it today which I
think is kind of like well I think
that's why his legacy has endured for
such a long time he was like pretty much
he was such a chameleon that he could be
everything to everyone well he was not a
musician
and he would never claim to be a
musician he didn't like being called a
musician he was an Entertainer
all right and he was a great Entertainer
he was an Entertainer along the lines of
[ __ ] you know um
you know uh Frank Sinatra or you know
but he was well I mean he was an artist
yeah I mean just a general artist and
and his and performance was his art form
and what what he really wanted to be was
an actor so his his art was kind of a
medium for his acting skills that's why
he's whenever he comes out with a new
new album he's gonna bring a new
character The Thin White Duke or he's
going to bring in [ __ ] Ziggy Stardust
or he's gonna you know it's it's a
different character a Major Tom you know
um so
he was multimedia you know he was he was
he was doing everything once he's way
ahead of his time do do it with a
limited medium of the day yeah I mean it
was very cross-promotion because well
because he was like a renaissance man he
could do a lot of different things and
he was interested in a lot of different
things
so he was interested in the way you
could cross-pollinate like music with
movies and perfumes and performance
right right right you're right so he was
like you said very ahead of his time way
ahead of his time because he really was
on the really had his finger on the
pulse of that of that [ __ ] yeah and he
knew how to be just subversive enough to
get away with something that was he was
rude but not quite subversive enough
that he was going to get him into like
trouble right he never really which is a
hard that's a very hard balance to to
walk actually because he he's trying to
keep himself in the mainstream see
so if you push it too hard and now now
sudden you can't be in the mainstream
anymore so be but then if you push it
too far in the other direction then
you're going to be lame and you're gonna
like lose all you and you're going to
lose all your hardcore fans he was very
much a promotional genius a genius of
[ __ ] concept
one of the greatest things ever to come
out of England
Bowie you know yeah across many artistic
media not just music yeah although I
kind of feel like music was probably
where he had the greatest influence but
we did a lot of stuff out in the music
scene that you wouldn't know about like
he he backed a lot of [ __ ] axed and a
lot of artists he backed [ __ ] Bauhaus
yeah
um Bauhaus was Bowie's favorite band for
a while that's really kind of why
[ __ ] Bauhaus kind of because
hunger and [ __ ] did they love Bowie yeah
um Ben asked what we thought of absolute
beginners I remember seeing it and not
loving it but I haven't seen it for a
very very long time so I really need to
like re-watch it uh probably my favorite
Bowie movies I love the hunger
um and I love I don't know if you guys
have ever seen this one but it's called
the linguine incident yeah I remember
that that was with Bowie and Rosanna
Arquette yeah I remember that I remember
I remember like it I remember really
really like yeah I haven't seen it in a
while but I saw it a bunch of times back
in the day I used to have it on VHS when
Bowie passed [ __ ] they played nothing
but Bowie at the club that [ __ ] that
that went after he but yes it was kind
of a sad day but Bowie went out and
everybody was crying Bowie went out on a
strong note a whole [ __ ] great career
with a great body of material across
different [ __ ] mediums uh he died
strong died making [ __ ] videos
died making videos about his upcoming
death with dark star and all that for a
black star excuse me and no he went out
doing it you really couldn't ask for a
better way to go out
yeah cancer is a bad way to go
but he went out being the artist that he
was he didn't mope about it he said [ __ ]
it I'm gonna do some death videos I'm
going back to the [ __ ] black stuff
the Black Star on the center of the
earth gonna go back with Major Tom
waiting for me over there you know just
the videos well yeah that's the thing if
you're leaned into it yeah I mean that
kind of mindset it's like yeah you
probably get to a point where like what
else can you do one and like yeah so you
might as well right
so you know you kind of get to a point
where you just kind of accept it and
you're like well die to cancer the
[ __ ] still look good
yeah still look good for an old dude
Dyna cancer I mean he's puffy but
[ __ ]
he was dying yeah yeah
it's wild John Smith said people forget
Mick Jagger was an actor too he was
amazing in performance yeah he was good
in that he's still alive and he yeah
yeah he's pretty much playing Mick
Jagger he was in
um
Ned Kelly too was he noticed he played
Ned Kelly we used a show about Ned Kelly
like not too long ago
you know what I mean John Smith also
said uh John Lennon was worth 800
million dollars in 1980.
when he got that's when he got shot
right in 1980. yeah I don't know how he
made was making his money probably
making his money off [ __ ] record uh
record uh [ __ ] residuals and stuff
well like I said a lot of musicians well
a lot in Paul McCartney and stuff like
that that's what I was thinking of
before is that a lot of musicians that
had a lot of staying power and still
stayed Rich were because they invested
their money into other things yeah they
didn't just like blow it all on like
Coke and hookers yeah yeah they had a
lot of them just did [ __ ] like buy
restaurants that's one of the things
that they heard a lot of did a lot of
the metal guys bought restaurants
[ __ ] bad business to buy if you don't
know I was just gonna say it's like if
you do that yeah I mean haven't they
ever seen Kitchen Nightmares I didn't
know back then
restaurants are probably one of the
worst businesses to buy if you're good
thinking thinking of investing in a
business yeah but the thing about
restaurants that's crazy is that
everybody thinks they can run one but
very few people can run one successfully
and like what is it 80 of them like go
out of business like in the first year
some ridiculous number never even worked
in a dish pit washing dishes I mean it's
different if you were a chef you like
that a line cook right and you're gonna
[ __ ] run a restaurant no no you're
not no you're not no you're not spoiler
alert no you're not
no you have to know a kitchen inside and
out before you can run a business or
you'll never know if a [ __ ] cook is
lying to you you'll never know if a cook
is good or bad you know they won't know
how to expect the cook's work [ __ ]
does a lot of [ __ ] that you and the
thing about it is that even if you have
even if you're a chef even if you've
worked in kitchens all your life a lot
of those [ __ ] open restaurants
and some of those fail too well a lot of
them are still trying to [ __ ] punch
above their weight they want to be these
[ __ ] fancy [ __ ] chefs instead of
shutting the [ __ ] up and just make it a
hamburger okay then it has a lot to do
with it
trying to be the star of the show I'm a
great cook so I'm gonna [ __ ] make
this fantastic food even though my local
clientele can't afford it and even
though they don't know what I'm doing
yeah that's the thing too you have to
yeah like you can get away with that in
some markets sure like because there's a
lot of successful restaurants like that
but you know it depends on where you
open the [ __ ] yeah you gotta like Gordon
Ramsey going to that one dude [ __ ]
he's selling all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
artsy fartsy [ __ ] food he goes no man
fish and chips
yeah because I don't want to do that
fish and chips everybody and then he had
that dude with the Tate Ruby Tate that's
right yeah that was one of the British
ones yeah and he [ __ ] cleared all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] out of there and
turned it into a real Spartan looking
that was the one that had the modern art
with the with the panties with the
crusty panties on there yeah yeah he
cleared all that [ __ ] out painted in
white so it looked like a [ __ ] just a
stark hotel or to start starting that
hard to look like a stark [ __ ]
Hospital
and just sold [ __ ] real good fish and
chips in the place was [ __ ] packed
and they got all kinds of money because
it's just fish and chips
people know what fish and chips are
and they'll come in and buy some fish
and chips
I mean the thing about it is that I feel
like nowadays
um you know since more people are
Foodies and more people are more
familiar with the stuff so you can get
away with a lot more but I still kind of
feel like your best bet is to focus on a
little bit of more of a niche market
um don't have a huge menu but just be
the [ __ ] best at that you know what I
mean it's like if we're gonna do tacos
we're gonna do tacos but like a slight
spin on them but still recognizable
tacos but we're gonna make the best
[ __ ] tacos that you've ever had and
that's it here in Florida we got food
trucks they change some of the laws to
where the food trucks can't go downtown
which I don't really agree with that no
I don't either I think a food truck
should be able to go where the [ __ ] it
wants to go
well within reason as long as it's not
blocking traffic right
um they had one it was called [ __ ]
500
554 what was that called 5 000
Fahrenheit or something like that it was
a pizza truck it's a [ __ ] big old
black Pizza truck
yeah we used to have it around the
corner from our house sometimes it would
show up with a [ __ ] huge Kiln in the
back of their with [ __ ] super hot
[ __ ] pizza oven and every time that
[ __ ] Pizza truck showed up there's a
[ __ ] line
there's like 60 people waiting to get
pizza
because the pizza was [ __ ] good real
good
well [ __ ] for a long time when they
still have food trucks in downtown
Orlando one of the most popular ones is
that [ __ ] cupcake truck the cupcake
truck and honestly they had been asking
where the cupcake truck was because yeah
they had a Facebook page and they had
all their Pages where they told you
where they were going to be like because
they'd be every day they would only have
four different cupcakes yeah like they
had two flavors that I think were like
all the time just like chocolate and
vanilla and then every day they would
have two different ones it was like
crazy [ __ ] they'd show The Cupcake you'd
show pictures of it to be posting it up
on Facebook showing what the cupcake is
you have this [ __ ] beautiful
black chocolate looking cupcake with
green frosting on it and a thing and
then a [ __ ] half a damn Snicker bar
stuck on the top of it and just with
like it had candy on it yeah candy bars
on The Damp and then it was just and it
was pretty man real pretty
and I never had one but everybody said
that no I told you and if there was
stuff and there was stuff in the cake I
think it was candy in the cake too and
they said it was just like a
hypoglycemic attack if you ate that well
like I said they would come up with they
had a couple flavors that were like all
the time you could always get them but
then like they would have a couple that
they would switch out from day to day so
you never really knew like today we're
gonna do like some like coconut caramel
or something like that so they would do
something different like every single
day so it was always different so it
would kind of like encourage people that
come back every day and see what the
different thing was gonna be but I told
you at [ __ ] uh Disney Springs AKA
Downtown Disney is what it used to be
called but it's called Disney Springs
now they have that [ __ ] Cookie Shop
there
that has a [ __ ] five hour
waiting list yeah people come there like
I said the only reason I got a cookie in
there was because my sister and brothers
had put in the line like hours before I
got there and by the time I got there
like we waited around for an hour to
like do another [ __ ] and then finally
like our turn came and they called us
and we went into the Cookie Shop But
like after we left they said oh yeah the
the line is five hours long now like for
the Cookie Shop
Gideon's bake house it's called and it's
kind of like
um I didn't want to say it was like it's
not Harry Potter theme but it is it's
like Tim burtony looking it's like a you
can't eat in there it's just like really
small but it looks like an old like
Gothic library in there but basically
you just go in and there's like a little
line like probably only 10 people can go
in there at a time
all they have is cookies cake and coffee
that's it
um you know and they have like I think
four different cookie flavors that they
have all the time and then seasonally
they have two different ones or two or
four different ones oracle's talking
about how good that barbecue truck is in
Texas yeah yeah they got good barbecue
trucks here too [ __ ] Florida and
Texas probably the same kind of
situation where because of the weather
and just the way everything's laid out
probably the Lost trucks those trucks
are [ __ ] good and when you think of
maybe people haven't seen it they would
think Pizza truck that's got to be like
just some bold [ __ ] dirty ass no not
not anymore you know a truck looks like
a beautiful tour bus
black with big [ __ ] huge graphics on
it you know [ __ ] pizza and
that was beautiful
well food trucks are available because
restaurant well because I kind of feel
like and this is going back probably
like 10 20 years at this point like in
the whole food scene
is that uh food trucks are a good way to
I don't think they're as trendy as they
used to be but they're a really good way
to get into the market because there's
not a lot of investment you know you
know what I mean yeah it's expensive you
have to buy a truck and kid it out and
everything like that but if you have
like a really good concept and you have
like a really good area it's a lot
cheaper to run than and if you have
something that really resonates with
people then you can make quite a bit of
money on the main the main advantage is
uh your moving location yeah uh you're
not [ __ ] stuck in one location if it
gets dead you can [ __ ] pick the
[ __ ] restaurant up and if there's a
special event like in the town like if
it's a holiday and they're having like a
street fair or something like that
obviously you can like go over there and
you're honestly move into where the
action is now downtown Orlando the
restaurants got [ __ ] pissed and they
[ __ ] Lobby to make sure that no food
trucks because they didn't want the
competition because they were paying for
rent and then they were getting their
asses beat by the damn food trucks and
I'm like we'll make your food better
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
the way I'm thinking is this I'm kind of
a laissez-faire capitalist in that way
well then that means restaurants aren't
that good that's what I'm saying if the
food trucks are beating that right maybe
maybe the future is food trucks you know
yeah you can have restaurants but don't
[ __ ] see downtown
the restaurants that were there were
kind of second-rate pizza parlors and
second-rate taco shops that could were
open at night serving to the bar crowd
so it was supposed to like drunk people
mostly drunk people which they were good
they were good but I mean the pizza is
good the tacos are good but it's like
you're drunk so pretty much like
anything it's gonna be better is not to
have those restaurants there people
don't need those to survive they got
grocery stores and [ __ ] you sh you have
[ __ ] another store there like [ __ ]
you know CBD shop or some [ __ ] like
that and then four or five [ __ ]
trucks running around that's different
with different different [ __ ] selling to
everybody the future might have been in
trucks I would love a breakfast food
truck because like I said when I'm drunk
I always wanted breakfast food and it
always bummed me out that there wasn't a
breakfast like an all-night breakfast
place
in downtown or at least like not
anywhere walkable like from the where
the club used to be there is a pizza
place which has been there since I was a
kid uh and the pizza is good I mean it's
not great but it's good
and then there was for a time there was
that taco place I don't even know if
that's there anymore and then for a time
there was a Chinese
place that was uh that was okay we ate
there a couple of times I would have
a a breakfast truck that did nothing but
just muffins and biscuits like the
sandwiches like McMuffin sandwiches and
make in the biscuit sandwiches like a
breakfast sandwich sandwich yeah I mean
that would be that's a great idea
yeah
they're easy to make it's cheap right
and everything who doesn't love
breakfast sandwiches
and you can say well I like a omelet I
said have an omelette McMuffin yeah put
an omelette make an omelet cut it in
half stack the two halves on top of each
other
yeah there you go
we're on a burrito I don't know
omelette McMuffin
I say McMuffin you can't say Mick you
just gotta say you might be able to say
mick how could they prove it I don't
know is McMuffin they would they would
save you yeah I'm a solid Nick with
m-i-c muffin they would probably still
see it
too close well they have a case like if
they think that like somebody could
legitimately like confuse the [ __ ] for
the real thing then right you can
totally see you and they'd probably win
yeah because they have like deeper
Pockets than than you have well didn't
McDonald's wasn't there a case
this was a while back now but wasn't
there a case where they sued
a little restaurant in Scotland that was
called McDonald's and they actually like
called it McDonald's because that was
their name his name yeah
um and I don't even think they I don't
remember but I don't even think they
have the same kind of food as McDonald's
maybe they did but yeah McDonald's
looking was a fast food version of the
[ __ ] egg eggs yeah it is that's
basically what it is I love to expect I
like eggs Rockefeller too have you had
that
you ever had eggs Rockefeller it's like
an Egg McMuffin but it had locks and it
had [ __ ] spinach
yeah I could eat that I don't think I've
ever had it but it sounds pretty good
it's almost time for us to [ __ ] oh
Oracle says this is a very foodie town
so food trucks need to be good yeah
they're all they're all good here I kind
of feel like nowadays
um you really can't slack because
there's so much like I said nobody is
it's not like the 70s where people just
eat whatever no you know what I mean
everybody is a lot more Savvy about that
[ __ ] nowadays so it's like if your
food's shitty then like you know
nobody's even in the 80s people ate
whatever yeah I was gonna say yeah I
would go up to Michigan and some of the
Italian restaurants in Michigan were
these [ __ ] Italian stodgy ass attack
and all the food tastes the same even
though they were independently owned
just because they all bought for the
same [ __ ] suppliers yeah Cisco or
Cisco or something U.S Food Service they
all tasted the exactly my ex-husband
used to work for the best food service
the same [ __ ] Pizza the same
strawberry the same [ __ ] is all the
[ __ ] say look let's go ahead and end
the show Jen and I'll make something to
eat [ __ ] starving we've been up for
more than two hours yeah two hours and
34 minutes time we can run it all right
so hopefully you had a good time hanging
out with us this Friday night this
Christmas Eve Eve so hopefully everybody
has a good holiday if you're celebrating
if you're traveling or something like
that please be safe and have a good time
we might come on Christmas Day and talk
about a Christmas horror movie we'll see
how it goes I mean I'll announce it
probably if we decide we're going to
come on so if anybody wants to hang out
with us on Christmas Day evening so uh
we'll see you guys maybe on Sunday if
not we'll see you on Monday for the uh
haunting show so good night and have a
good one